Test test
May 18, 2016
3:00 p.m.
Stage 7 Lee yoe     e
yoe       -Lee yoe        Lee
yoe
:00 p.m. PT
.   te to Firebase
.
.                    Pashgs
Google yoke
Google I/O
2016.
May 18, 2016.
May 18, 2016
.
3:00 Pacific Time
Session AN9.
Behind the Scenes
.
What's catch new           New
in Android Accessibility
.
>> Mellow,
everyone                Hello,
everyone, welcome to behind the
scenes, what's new in Android
accessibility.  My name is
mooses        Maya Ben Ari,
product manager on Android
accessibility.  With me are a
couple of people from the
accessibility team.  We are
going to show you a couple of
new features, couple new demos,
Sill and a   ylvan
ilvano      ylvan     ill
unique look of behind the
scenes.  This is our agenda for
today.
We will give a brief overview
about accessibility.  We will
talk about what's new in
accessibility in Android, and we
will talk about the gesture
dispatch API and show a couple
of very cool demos.  Also we
will look through voice access,
a new service, new accessibility
service.  Then we will give a
brief look of behind the scenes
in U.S. research.
So, let's start.  What is
accessibility?  Accessibility is
about create ed, is about
create and products
ing products that are usable by
everyone, including people with
disabilities, such as motor
impairment or visual impairment.
But I'd like to rephrase this
definition as slightly different
.  I would say that
accessibility is about challenge
ing the assumptions we make
about our users. can the user
see the device or distinguish
between colors?  Can he or she
touch the device or hear back
the sound that the device is
producing?  Can the user speak
back to the device? this is not
a small number.  20 percent of
the user population will have
some sort of a disability during
their lifetime, according to
the U.S. census. not only that.
Challenge ing the assumption,
can been      benefit all the
users.  Why?  Because some of
the technologies that were
developed in the past, such as
speech recognition, or word
prediction, started as
technologies for user with
accessibility needs. this is not
all.  We are all accessibility
users sometimes.  This is called
situational disability.  When
we drive our car, we cannot look
at our phone.  When we are in a
noisy environment, we cannot
hear the sounds of the device
and we cannot speak back to the
device. carry heavy bags from
the supermarket, we cannot touch
the device.  So we want to
design an inclusive experience
for all users, regardless of
what restriction the user might
have.
Now, let me briefly mention some
of accessibility service and
features available on the
platform today.  So first, what
is an accessibility service?
This is a privilege, service
that changed the interaction
model with the device in one of
two ways     ways.  One, it can
change the way the user
interacts with the device, or it
can change the way that content
is presented to the user. the
first accessibility service we
have on the device today is talk
back.  Talkback is targeted for
people with vision impairment,
or blind, and it's basically a
screen reader.  The user can
interrupt with the device using
touch gesture, and content is
presented, content is spoken to
the user through text to speech.
The second accessibility
service is Braille back.
So can we switch to the demo?
Braille back is similar to talk
back, just in this case, the
user can interrupt with
something which is called a
Braille refreshable display.
The user can type through these
keys, or interact with this
joystick, and then the content
is presented using Braille in
those Braille cells with the
dots raising and lowering.
service is switch access.
Switch access is targeted for
motor impaired users who have
trouble interacting with the
touch display.  In this case, we
have something which is called
adaptive switch.  This adaptive
switch has two buttons.  The
user can configure one button as
next and one built       button
as select.  Using only these
two buttons, the user can
interact with the device, note
that the switch can be with more
or less buttons.
Can we switch back to the slides
?  The last accessibility
service is voice access.  In
voice access, the user can
perform low level interaction on
the device using only his voice
.  This is a new service that we
recently launched, and Patrick
and Scott from the accessibility
group will soon tell us more
about this one.
We also have a couple of
accessibility features already
baked into the platform.  For
example,
Pashgs  ing    ing?  Hi
.  Welcome.  So, I'm very good
very glad to be
because I can finally share with
you what  up to at Firebase.  A
Today, more than ever, has
the tools you need to build a
success ful    ful          I'm
also excited because...I kind of
came to I/O this      the long
way around.  I left a great job
at Google years ago.  I wanted
to dive into this app detail
develop thing and change
the world with a small up.  This
small start-up had a you
unique vision.   we could en
empofrp   wer developers by
lettinged to create and  back
end that needed to support that.
And      that start-up, of
course, was partly sunny
se.
So          Parse.  So, before
I oined Google and teamed up
with the Firebase team , I spent
three years on the partly sunny
se team.  Most
Parse team.   known as lead
develop er   er for partly sunny
se     Parse push
Push.  And in when there were
reliability and scaleability
tended to hit only the largest
I worked a lot between t
he backened     end develop
ae   nd   ae   end
developers and  team.  As a fowl
Fowler      fowl      former
partly sunny         se
Parse team member, hearing
shut down hurt me physically
and to anybody was a partly
sunny         se     Parse
customer in this room, I want to
express cere est    st a
pologies.  Nope      Nobody in
partly
sunny         se     Parse, nor
Firebase;  what's
happening
, happy with
what's happening here today.
We're not with the fain
pain you've gone through.   my
former teammates in partly sunny
se     Parse, I want to
express  I am that they've
response ive   e yibl      ibly
handled this tragedy   ic
Firebase gave a year notice they
were doing a down.  They gave
an open source implementation of
end and         ae   end and
dead  dicated themselves to
spend the next  ing    ing
customers migraine   te.  I
think we should all thank
thank you for Senate
setting
So, the advice I'm
going to give today is
Jen   generic.   have to have
been a     .  But...I've decided
to lay out the content to
people who are like me coming
from a partly sunny
Parse back end
Understand ing    ing all the
nefrp   w feet  atures available
in          We're going to
start today by looking at how
Firebase in the doing     Google
eek  cosystem.  And why
Firebase can help  if you
already have a back end     ae
end.  , we're going to look
at the set of products .    that
can help cover the feet  ature
gap .com and Parse serve er
Server.          Then,
we're going to cover some novel
feet  atures, you   unique
Firebase, that have no Parse
alternate ive and finally,
deep into the internals of how
you build your app  see how
Firebase' approach gives  never
, new tools.          So,
we welcome you to Google.  No
matter where       where you are
what you might already be
running your ication on, even if
it's Parse serve er
Server.  Because with
you can build just about
anything.  You know,  look at
back ae   end service, we tip
ypically compare it       to
one of four alternate
itudes.  At the very bottom
we have an rastructure as a
service.  These give      give
us the raw  blocks we can use to
build any back ae   end, as
long  the time and expertise.
In doing     Google, this  means
Google compute engine
Compute Engine,
where you can         you   cess
to raw virtue al    al machines
or Google contain er  where you
can scale up and down instances
.  If , you can go up the stack.
You can trade off  the
operation al   al response
ibility by use ing  as a service
.  Like Google app engine
App Engine or the up
Google Google Cloud
Cloud functions.        These
products let you continue
developing back ae   end while
not need ing    ing to worry
about which servers your
end runs on.  You can go the
next lay yer    er up on
yer    er up and use  as
a service like Firebase to hand
off some of mental response
ibility. S    ies.  Because,
backend as service provides a
sweet       suite of inter
grated feet  atures that a  to
spend most, or even all of your
time, focus on the client code.
we're not going to spend time
today covering        lasz t
level, software as a service,
but I listed here,,
it  to
remind you that Google is fairly
you   unique.  power ful    ful
and success ful    ful products
at all layers  stack, which
means, when you choose to
develop with  you're not cyto
stuck at only one alternate
itude.  You can  out.
agine if you have a backend
today written on Google
Compute Engine.
Odds are, if you're distribute
ing     ing files, use ing
ing Google          e ing
ing gloudz          e
ing     ing Google Cloud storage
to much      doo  so.
Tradition  if you wanted to give
users acre  cess to  you have
to create your own A pfk    PI
serve er   r to control has acre
cess to which files.  , starti
ng today, you can use Firebase
storage       Storage.  backend
as a service lay yer    er on
top of the infra    goo
Google Cloud storage.  This will
let  a simple rules file to
describe for your entier  should
have acre  cess and it saves
you the need need ing    ing to
manage and scale a service
between your and your users.
Simple   ilarly, you'll
also be able to go down the
stack.      , I'm announce ing
ing the upcoming goo
Google Cloud ully inter grate
with Firebase.  You'll be  react
to changes that happen in the
Firebase eek .          So...
this means that if you already
have a backend, .  And if it's
at a different alternate
itude from  that's also
fine.  If you've migraine   ted
from  to Parse serve er
Server, you've
you've gone from a backnd  end
at service to infrastructure or
platform as a service. that's
the right choice for your team,
I encourage  stick with it chlt
.  Because Firebase can help
you, no  your exist ing    ing
solution is today.
, we have a series of feet
atures that cover the  between
Parse.com and Parse serve er
r.  These  crash reporting,
Parse an
Crash Reporting,
Parse an lit    alytics
Analytics, Parse host
Parse config      Config.
Firebase has products in all
these areas.  Let's look  you
can recover these product areas
and do more you ever could
before.   and foremost, you
should check out Firebase an
This is the crown jewel of the
nefrp   w Firebase .  You don't
need to add code to start use
ing     ing it and  no charge,
no matter how many A pfk    PI
requests send.          If you
have complex analysis needs,
Firebase an lit      Analytics
grate with Google bit
questionnaire          ry
Bit Query will let you
slice  your data as you see fit
and an lit    alytics
Analytics, sets
sets the  many other inter
grations with Firebase products
, this is our new an lit
alytics idea      dear
dear      dashboard.  Ads     As
you'll  the most important feet
ature is at the top.   are use
ing     ing your application?
We sliced that down
daily, weekly and monthly users
of your app so understand the
next engagement.         Next,
you can scroll down and see ret
ention could he      horts.   a
fans cy word for do your users
keep use ing     ing your  do
they get board       bored with
it?  Retention could he
horts  your use yer    r
base based on which which week
they d use ing     ing your app.
You can look overtime
vertically  line and see
when did people stop use ing
ing my app?         Now,
you'll also notice this dashb
oard is show ing    ing  users
age 25 to 34.  This application
wasn't  providing that
information to Firebase.  With
you automatically get power ful
ful information,  ing    ing
any code, you understand where
your new  are coming from, how
many of them are coming back, ,
they're use ing     ing your app
when they do, and even
information like their agenda
gender, age, country, s.
All in a free product.   if
you'd like, you can add extra
information for     alytics
Analytics as well.  You
can describe custom attribute
users or provide up to 5 hnd
00 custom types of  like to
send.  And you can use this
dive deep er   er into your
groups.
But if you to compose that, you
can do so in add  udiences.
Add    let you describe a
collection of users who
characteristics and
into a        demographic in
your app and understand how they
use it  also use eu    add
udiences to reen  -engage
customers in application.  Use
ing     ing Firebase
notifications, or config.
I said, you don't need to add
code to use an lit
Analytics.  It's part of
the core SDK, but if like to add
additional properties, you can
say set     r property string or
you can log additional events
event with name,  parameters.
Asks      It's that ease y.  .
..if you are like me, you
occasionally write in
im ware and...
one of the biggest problems I
track ing    ing down what went
wrong in the field.  The  you
get a bug report, it's hard to
translate  use yer    r is
describe ing to an actual crash
dumb p. second time you get a
bug report, you need to tree  is
this a new issue or should I
save myself time not debug this
because it's already known?
When you  third crash report, it
seems familiar, you need
figure out whether or
not this is a known issue  been
fixed or whether that bug has
reGreg
reGreg     d and
crash reporting can help you
solve   of these important
problems.  , in the crash report
ing dashboard, you can
see at a, how many crashes
crashes are happening in
your app  There's three
important
, we've
grouped them together into crust
lusters.  Crust    lusters
ors with simple   ilar stack
traces and likely have the
cause.  This can greatly help
you tree  iage and into the
individual reports that you see.
You can   iage by how many use
rs are impacted by these
Now, when we scroll down into
crust    lusters, you can see we
have detailed information.  We
see the stack  the latest
version that this app is crashed
for, you can also dive into
every single error that  reports
have detailed information.
what device was running this app
.  understand whether that
device was jail broken.
how much memory was available
in the  where       what
wrouchl         country it was
in.  You can understand why
on was I     Wi-Fi or cellular.
One great feet  ature
Android is that you can report
non- fate al       fatal errors
as  You don't have to wait for a
crash to improve  your app.
Crash reporting
reporting also comes without
code by default.   of the core S
DK on an  Android.  In I ofking
pod.  However...you can make
ease ier     ier if you'd like
to add a little bit of
First, Firebase crash
crash.log reports this.
And a non- fate al
fatal     - fatal
fatal error, Firebasec
rash.report.          Now...if
you have an exist ing    ing
backend, odds are you have a
serve er   r that is able to
host web kon tent
content.
you check out a dead  dicated
host ing  It can make your life
much ease ier you can use a sim
ple command .  Which is Firebase
redeploy, you deploy an en  re
copy of your static website.  If
you screws up  an issue, you
can safely get back to a well-
use ing     ing fire base
e ing     ing
Firebase roll balk      back.
locally with the same software
that we use  infrastructure.
Firebase host ing    ing is
fast
ing        Hosting is fast.  It
automatically inter  content
delivery networks to make sure
is deliver aechd quickly a
ed quickly across the
globe and  secure.  We're SSL
first.  We manage all of the
that you need to handle to serve
as a      secure con  You just
give us files, and we give you a
fast  network.
Firebase host ing    ing is
so ease y to use, I actually
strug to come up with a
follow-up slide here.  So,  I
decided to give an announcement.
Starting  Firebase host ing
Hosting supports custom
doe mains absolute .
Now our final product
app between Parse
remote config
Remote Config.
It's a power ful    ful  I'm
happy to share t it with you
today.   need die nam
ynamic content in your app
lication,  database isn't really
the right place to put it.
Firebase
remote config             Remote
Config let's you store die nam
ynamic content Parse conf
ig      Config did, except you
have the ability  what you're
sending according to the
Democrat        demographics
use yer    r.  You can send
different con figs to .
agine you've written a
newspaper  Newspapers of old had
headlines.  We're going to
into our application.  That
headline is meant to gagement
and will do so with relevance.
With  config             Remote
Config, you can target national
users who are in a particular
Kuru      country.  If you ple
headlines, you can do a tested
rollout and  rollout to doo  AB
test ing    ing to see whether
or  nefrp   w headline is
driving the edge      engagement
you          If you're a multi
-Marin       ling     lingual
product, you can add trans  in
your remote cog     config, by
providing a config based on the
language of the device  cess ing
ing this.         And if you
have particular interest groups
within your  those will
probably be in an lit    alytics
Analytics.  You'll have
an add  udience for people who
love snowballed
snowboard  look      love
Google.  So, you can past
post all  I ofk    /O news he'll
adlines to people in the add
udience in an lit
Analytics.          Use
ing     ing remote config is
Remote Config is
ease y.  There are three things
to doo  to get started.  You
want to provide off faults.
These will be used before your
or any time the cash value is
too old to able.  , you can tell
remote config to fetch or fetch
duration.  This will make sure
you get a  of remote config
Remote Config if it
has expired. , finally, once
remote config             Remote
Config has acre  cessed the ,
it doesn't automatically make it
available.   pretty bad if you
started configure ing     ing
your app  set of con
date in between.   line activate
fetched helps you coordinate
copies  config with how your app
lication flows.  Once  latest
copy of remote config, you can
use  lodge   gic like you would
a dictionary.  Use and tacks and
act as any property by name and
a wrapper object back where
you can get, spools, whatever
you'd like.
feet  atures help us gain
parent a          parrot   ity
from Parse serve er
Server  what we had in
Parse.com.  we go onto the
things that are the core f of
your  you might need to choose
between one backend , I want to
give a brief shout out to some
novel feet  atures that are you
unique to Firebase.  , we have
die nam      ynamic links.  Die
nam      ynamic links ares for
your application.  They can
share the location tent deep
within your app.  They work even
for use  don't have the app in
stalled yet.         SHA  hazam
has been invesz ting n in die
nam      ynamic links recently
by  ing    ing with coke  ca
koel         Coca-Cola to print
them on their bottles
bottles  get a
warm welcome for users that want
tri-      try out f   the app
lication         In case you're
not fortunate enough to partner
with  ca koel         Coca-Cola,
we have another product for you
.  With vites, your users can
send these die nam      ynamic
their friends regardless of
whether or not  ing     ing your
app.
And then you can improve or
index ing    ing allows the
doing     Google search engine
to crawl die nam      ynamic
links in your app and provide
deep links  app's content in
Google search results.  , since,
like I said, I'm fallible and
many of you are as well, we have
Firebase test lab        Test
Lab for an  This will let you
automate your app on many s
owned by doing     Google.  You
can get much  test coverage
without having to buy every an
that
increase paid growth in your
application by      ing the
nefrp   w inter grations with
doing     Google ad words
Ad Words.         Words.  You
can your ads to that Democrat
demographics
Democrat        demographic
and you can earn  your app
lication by use ing     ing
Google AdMob that  advertise
ments in your application.
, now the meet      meat of the
talk.  The remain ing    ing
products more central to the way
you build an application. s, AU
authentication, and data.  So
there did           they a deep
er   er look.  Fear      First
and foremost, notification have
a special place in mchl   y
heart.   two products in this
sort of area.  Google
ing           Messaging is now
Firebase cloud     Cloud message
ing           Messaging.  This
that provides a low-level
service for
ing content directly to an app,
for push ing    ing data to
.  It is still free
psychiatry            freely
available, access yibl     ible
from the  pfk    PIs and is the
platform that other providers,
like  urban hair      ar
Urban Airship already use
today for     to reach your
from their purse       push
platforms.         Nothing in
Firebase cloud     Cloud message
ing           Messaging
requires you to  fire
Firebase services.  On top of
that, we built s.
This is the set of products
will help you use information
you gained   to more acre
curately target your users and
create  for those users.
So, let's look at the nefrp
w dashb
oard.  Obviously a  er   r
should let you type in a.  You
can also schedule the
notification to  now or later.
You can schedule it to be now,
an exact time in the future, or
a time       relative to the use
yer    r's device ing    .  If
you have that news ication, you
can schedule the push to be sent
every at 8:30 at the use yer
r's time zone.
the real power of Firebase
notifications  its target ing
ing framework.  With Firebase
, you can use all of that rich
knowledge  in Firebase an lit
Analytics to target your
users  like.  You can target
your users with the  udiences
you've created.   you're mover a
Parse push to channel the
person, then I  out topics.
They're the same John
general , you subscribe to a top
ic and receive pushes  that topi
c.  The main difference between
push to  use ing     ing topics
is that topics is about 50  er
And then, finally, if
you're test ing    ing an
individual       device, you can
use this console to target just
your  that you can be confident
you haven't just headline
llo world to your enpicture
use yer               tier  re
use yer    r base.  I have seen
happen, actually.  It's not the
greatest page to
, Firebase notifications inter
grates with Firebase
Analytics in both direction
s.  You can use an lit
alytics to  you want to en
gage and you can use an lit
alytics  whether or not you
use     successfully eng
udience.   automatically
measure how     how many pushes
were sent and were opened, but
we will also be able to
conversion of    event if you
apply one.  , you know, in this
example, we have asked the use
to look at a new talk.  Or
Our goal here is that they star
that session, they'll add the
talk to their.  If you do so, it
will shoch up in our an
show up in
our an lit
Analytics funnel.
understand more about Firebase
notifications and  message ing
Cloud Messaging,
check out these two talks.  We
CM is now FCM, which covers that
foundation
foundation al  On top of it, we
have Firebase notification
everything you need to know in
45 minutes , I'm going to give a
lot of shout outs to
outs  talks, I'll post them all
on the spaces after  You don't
need to take pictures of every
slide.         Firebase author
author
author      Auth describes who
is use ing     ing your app.
It's  same providers you     you
used to expect and more.
importantly, Firebase author
Auth allows you to provide
own backend service to control
your end AU  authentic and it
Firebase author, it's so pow
pow
Auth, it's so power
implement log in   in where you
log into  ing     ing a Parse
session token.  , for any
service, if you have Parse serve
er        Server, which going
to stay around, that might be a
fine strategy. are on Parse.com,
I recommend that you use,  a
the client side.  When someone
tries to in, you'll try to log
in against Firebase.  If that
ceed, but does credentials that
you still have in your app to a
new use yer    r in Firebase and
then migraine   te the  Parse
use yer    r over to your
Firebase database.  , Firebase
sessions have the same power of
Parse , except we use crypt
Colonelfy sped      instead of
the
Krog              yog
ography instead of the data .
It includes all of the things
you'd have had  PF session
object, except it's enkoed
coded and by your app's
product key.  This means, you
can  sure that the session is
valid, which use yer    r it ,
when it's supposed to expire and
any custom  have from your
personal author      Auth
service.  Rules  particular
session is from an I ofk    OT
device and  should have res
tricted acre  cess.  can all be
verify ied directly on the
session toke  without having to
make an extra A pfk    PI
request for  that you make.
Firebase author      Auth inter
grates with Firebase rules.  In
system like Parse rngs every
, every object
describes its own acre control.
And as an app administrator,
this can to unsernt
certainty.  Because you
can't actually add  udit   cess
control in your system and
unless you read your entier  re
catch        er  re app's con
tents         Even worse?  If
you need to update information
or  your application, if you
need to give admins  cess, you
would have to doo  a full data
migration of tier  re
application for this to work.
Instead,       Auth and Firebase
ask the         security rules
allow you to  one file, the
rules that should be applied
entier  re systems.  Your enfire
tier  re Firebase database
or tier  re Firebase storage
bucket.  And you can know,
confidence, that these rules are
applied everywhere
, you can learn more about
identity and author
Firebase with three key talks.
First, the key to Firebase
security.  This will go over e
languages you'll use to secure
the realtime database  storage.
Next, to
focus on the actual log in   in
experience, we have  for a great
sign in experience.  And one
pitch a few times is zero to app
cap               Zero to App,
:   Firebase.  This talk
combines off the database  to
create three apps with live code
ing     ing.  We'll someone
live code ing     ing at all
times for I ofk     iOS, an
Android .  So nobody's left
out in the talk. , next, if we.
..there we go.  If you have
large of data, a database is not
the right place to put chlt
.  So, for blobs       blobs
of rich data, we have Firebase
Storage.  The Firebase
lay yer    er on top of the pet
PETA    petabyte
Google Cloud storage product
Storage Product.
if you look at our dashboard,
the first thing  on our dashb
oard is that Firebase storage is
a stand alone product.  You
can look at your , you can mod
ify them, upload them and you
to wrap your files inside other
objects.
we have a rules tab.
Firebase products are secure ,
not just things that is    point
to them.  Data  is secure, even
if the URLs leak out.   you can
delete files directly.  There's
no more collection required.
And there's no more ten
megabyte limit for files you
use in Firebase Storage.  llows
you to doo  download and upload
resume ing ily.  ...Parse has
not yet decided the migration
strategy .com and Parse files.
But there is a get
peed         Wikipedia page
which I'll post in the spaces
after this
.  Because is    Parse serve er
Server already has a plug
play adapt er   er for Parse
files.  You can use Google
storage       Storage.  There's
an official node module.  Since
built on Google Cloud storage,
it's reverse
use one backend to have data
that  a Parse file and Firebase
Storage.
Now, they you save the best for
last
This is the original .  It's why
470,000 developers trust
today.  The Firebase database
Database started years
ago by let  of preconceptions of
how a database needs to.  We
don't need to have unstructured
data just  some collection.  We
can lay out our data to  way we
plan to present it in our app
lication.  we don't need to
restrict ourselves to some rest
ful .  Rest is nice because it's
ease y to think  so Firebase
does support rest for the
realtime , however, we believe
that being a cut it chlt     .
Dragging to refresh is
going to be as old to
tomorrow as     ing refresh to
check your e-mail is today.  ...
while on other systems, you
might have to save an  have a
cloud code trigger, send a push
have that show up in your
device, issue a questionnaire
ry, update your UI, re-
realize that not everybody
notifications enabled and also
have a poll loop damages your
battery life and isn't very
response  so add extra are     U
I that allows you to over load
poll refresh.        Let's just
make the data sink   ync.
Describe the data you  and it
pushes the devices in mill
iseconds.  So,  we've done this
is by restructuring how we show
Data in a Firebase database is
build       built like a giant J
SON document or a giant tree. '
node      in that tree and say
"I care about this" ."   said
you like to listen to a point in
the base, and     any changes
to that will be in  Intel
streamed down to your device.
Now...this requirement
is                requires us to
have an unfamiliar structure
you can see familiar concepts
show up.  look at the first top
level      -level keys here,
they're  and presenters.  Now
these are the  collections,
which should sound familiar.
Your first ept in most databases
, your table or your class.
same way in Firebase.  , next,
underneath the presentations
collection, see some jib
gibberish, some numbers.  More
commonly  Rand    random
advantages            strings.
This is how you have a list  in
Firebase.  We have a tool called
a push ID will Jen   generate a
Rand    random stream based on
the serve  stam     stamp.  This
allows you to insert data into
insert data into a list while a
void ing .          With this
type of layout, though, you
consider these the object IDs in
our collection.  And underneath
object IDs, you'll see that all
of the next keys  same
structure.  These are our
objects in        document
object model.          Now...s
ome of these keys make sense.
Location, title,  are just
strings.  They last
This last one is a  curious.
It's a bit nested, it's
structured.  What ?  The first
key is that title.  Presenters.
you remember, that was a name
of our other space.  And
remember how I said that, list
of  garbage strings or arrays?
This is the name  name space
being mapped to a key or to an a
rray of
.          If we scroll down.
..we'll notice that presenters
has a       named inlien
lined.  This is how we can
structure    al data in Firebase
.  We have the name or value one
key point ing    ing to basic
ally a template parameter or
inside the database somewhere
else.          That's how you
can use that one reference to
have a of objects or list a   of
pointers to objects elsewhere
database.
is a new and novel approach.  I
know it might a little int
imidate ing at first, so I want
ed to a case study from sky skan
scanner.  Sky skan
scanner is a  app in Europe.
They have over 5 million ive
customers.
And they built a modern web
web
and wanted to know how they
were doing.  They  feet  ature
where they asked the customer, "
how  you?  "  If the customer
was happy, they'd in the use yer
r to share their feedback on
the app store  the app with
their friends.  If the feedback
, they asked for feedback
directly.  This  another backe
nd.  They decided to try out
They said it took them ten hours
to rewrite whole feet  ature
use ing     ing Firebase.  It
took them two  test all their
inter grations with the new  and
took them two weeks to fully
roll their entier  re new code
base.  they say about it?  It
was ease y to switch fromlegacy
solution.  The web A pfk    PI
is premature for the base and
it's incredible y ease y to use.
, ...I'm going to, light and
fast, go  of migraine   te ing
ing data.  These are fund
amentally   They're structured
differently.  Tip  ypically talk
about a background sink   ync.
You have your old app,  a new
one in a clean room, you might
have some  transformer lodge
gic, but you can use that to
load import.  You can use that
to Secretary of State
test your new
app with ashot of old data.
You can drop that data if you
restart.  ...you need to restart
again and do sink   ync ing
ing with end.  To make sure
that when you have these two
they don't diverge.  This is a
bit of a  you need to sink   ync
at the same time as  over write
write old data.   some
cloud code for you
Cloud code for you that can
help you do types of migrations.
The other option you can do
your app and put it into read
only mode and your sink
ynchronization afterwards.
other option is a double write.
You start with  app, connect to
a new database with an app that
acre  cess to both copies.
First you trade yourase with the
source of truth and you might
do a  of data in the background.
As feet  atures become  or
are fully migraine   ted, you
can change your  truth to be the
hybrid app.  Sorry, to be the
w bak ckend.          Eventu
ally your old app stops being
Utesed        used, you can
your dependency on the old back
end and then your new app.
I said, I'm going to be sharing
-- oop! , there's two sessions
to dive in deep er   er.
Conceive              Dive into
the realtime database
Realtime
Database and zero app     to
app   App cap               Zero
to App.  We  an    a suite of
inter grated products designed
to im  app, grow your database
and earn money.  We you how you
can add novel tools to Firebase
or  and how Firebase' approach
to getting you  to building an
app gives you novel advantages.
So, remember,
migraine   te ing     ing to
Firebase doesn't need to
migraine   te ing     ing away
from something else.  We've
shown  the Firebase tools can
help you solve problems  you
haven't been able to before.
What's next?  We had
the            Join online, I'd
love to hear what  doing, what
you love about the nefrp   w
Firebase  we can improve.  Thank
you very much on behalf myself
and my partner, sill    Sylvan
ilvano, the
of my time in the tent or I'll
be at  afternoon sessions at I/O
.  Thank you.
Pashgs resentation clue
concluded at can     3:45
p.m. PT]         Pashgs
"This text is being
provided in a rough draft
format.
Increasing app quality with
testtesting
FB3 increasing app quality
with testing
.
Increasing App
Quality With Test
Testing
>> Hi, everyone, my name is
Ahmed.  I'm a developer at
Firebase test lab.  I'm joined
with me  Fergus  Ali.  I'm on
Firebase crash>> Michael B
Iordanis with Shazam.  will
help you with the quality and
testing with your apps.  We know
quality is superintendent to
-- is important to us.  We will
hear this throughout the
conference today.  We want you
to have the best possible apps,
build the best possible apps and
you need to make sure you have
quality to make your apps s
uccessful.  In fact, more than
51% of the one story views we
saw on the reviews on Google
Play are related to quality
issues.  Bugs and crashes.  Data
is clearly showing us we need
quality results and in this talk
we will talk to you about the
different tools that Google
offers to be able to manage your
quality throughout the life
cycle of your application
development.  Starting with
Firebase test lab, which allows
you to manage the quality of
your application during
development to the Play launch
report that was announced today
and allow you to manage the
quality of your app during the
release process.  And Firebase,
which was also announced and it
will help you prioritize the
most important and impactful
crashes and resolve them quickly
so they don't affect your
users.  Many of you heard about
cloud test lab, that was
announced last year.  We're now
proud to say we are part of the
Firebase family.  This is the
most amazing Googler products
released.  It is all in the
tools in one location and
Firebase test lab is part of
that suite of tools.   lab is
your first stop to manage
quality during the test process.
With Firebase test lab, we
want you to make sure your app
works well on the devices your
users have.  That is why the
first part to get started is the
infrastructure.  This is an
actual photo from our device
lab.  This is devices running in
our data centers, hosting them
from different manufacturer,
different API levels and form
factors.  The goal is to make it
easy to access these devices at
any time, don't worry about
building infrastructure or
buying more devices.  We have
that covered for you.  You build
your app and run it on this
amazing infrastructure.   second
part of Firebase test lab is
how it easily integrates with
your development work flow.  All
you need to get started is a
web browser and your app.  You
can upload your app to the
browser, start your test, and go
from there.  We also built an
integration with Android studios
so you can run your test during
developing Android studio and
built a command line interface
to use during your integration
If you use Jenkins you can see
it on the developers
documentation and the amazing
community built for construction
on how to use circle CI and
team city.  All of these docs
are available and we're adding
more and
more.  We agree that writing
test code is something we don't
want to invest in from the
beginning.  This is where we
built this robo crawler it
launches your app, clicks on
button as a normal user would do
do.  It builds the activity and
tracks the crash.  It is logging
use using Google and bypassing
the log-in using Google and was
able to find a crash near the
end.  It gives you the full path
leading to the crash so you can
resolve all of these issues.
Now, no matter how smart this
robo is, it probably won't be
able to guess your custom log-in
credentials.  We're building
the espresso test recorder at
Android studio.  All you have to
do with the first test to build
espresso, launch the app on
your phone, we capture all the
interaction you do and build a
full low -- fully reusable test
script for you.  is the most
impactful user journey, cover
them with test cases and every
new change to your code, make
sure the scenarios don't break.
are the most scenarios in your
app, you shouldn't break them by
any change.   lab provides a
full report with logs, screen
shots, stat traces and a video
to allow you to fix any issues
on your app, resolve them and go
back to a green
state.  So I mentioned that
Firebase test lab is basically
cloud test lab, which was
announced last year at I/O, but
now it is part of the Firebase
family.   to say we worked
really closely with our partners
and developers and they helped
us shape the product.  We ran
100 devices on the
infrastructure and believe we
can add much more than that.
Here's four square, they're
telling us how it was easy to
integrate Firebase test lab into
their work flow.  Also the
friends from KK box.  They were
able with the robo, by crawling
o application they were able to
resolve issues on launch on
their devices that they would
have never captured it otherwise
and would have affected users.
want to introduce Michael
Bailey.  We did a talk
previously, and I'm proud to do
my second talk in a row with
him.  Mike is a respectful and
highly influential in the
Android community.  I will leave
it up to him.  Yeah.  Thanks,
Ahmed.   we
We have an American Express
Android app.  When tools like
espresso came out we started to
verify it did what we wanted it
do to within r.  Set up a
physical device farm that
started on my desk with a bunch
of devices connected to a MAC m
ini, to run Jenkins and for
every branch we ran all the
tests to make sure we didn't
introduce defects.  That was
fine with a small number of
tests and didn't have that big
of an Android team.  Espresso
made it easy to write tests, we
wrote more because it helped us
increase quality.  We needed
more devices.  We had problems
problems connecting them to MAC
minis.  This grew and grew, and
more engineers, and more
requests, and more tests to run
on our infrastructure. A
constant refrain was I can't
merge my change because the
builds aren't passing because
the device is giving me
problems, can you unplug it,
replug it with USB to get the
test to run.  It was becoming a
maintenance burden.  It was a
daily refrain in our process to
run the tests and make sure they
were always passing.  It was
taking a lot of engineer and
hardware to run all the tests.
Last year a Google I/O I heard
about the Firebase Test Lab for
Android, about how I could run
my test on devicedevices
provided by Google.  I contacted
them, asked them for early
access.  Last July Ahmed and
team came to our office, got us
set up with cloud test lab.  By
August, we had decompensated our
own device farm and running all
our tests on
Cloud Test Lab.  By August, we
had decompensated our own device
farm and running all our tests
on Firebase Test Lab.  No more
did we have the complaints about
running all the tests, getting
to the last one, it fails and
you have to start the job all
over again.  We were able to add
more engineers and tests
without having to worry about
how are we going to get more
devices?  it slow down our whole
process?  So by switching to
this, we got more productivity,
able to get early access to this
tool, and we have a lot less
maintenance.  We can actually
focus ourselves on writing the
tests
and with making a high quality
app that card members expect.
Now I will turn it over to
Fergus from the Play team.
Thanks,
>> I'm very excited to be here
today to announce the prelaunch
report as part of the Play
developer console.  Ahmed talked
about, in the development life
cycle of building your app, you
should test it using Firebase
Test Lab, Jenkins plug-ins and
the command line.  When you are
about to release your app to the
1.2 billion monthly active Play
users.  Did I fix the issues,
is my app ready to be shown to
the users, how does it look?
That is where this comes in and
shines.  Before I go into what
is included in the prelaunch
board.  Hands up if you have an
app on Play today.  Keep your
hands up, if you tested that app
on more than 10 devices.  I'm
impressed.  Keep your hand up if
you got those results within an
hour.  Very impressive guy over
here.  I will show you how to
all keep your hand up when you
are asked that question in the
future as a result of the
prelaunch report.  That is
powered by Firebase Test Lab.
includes three parts, crashes,
screen shots, security.  In the
crashes section, we show you the
results of the robo that Ahmed
described, interacting with your
app for about five minutes,
across 10-plus physical Android
devices, and we show you if
there was a crash we show you
the stack trays, log cache,
device spec and a video of the
robot interacting with the
application.  This really helps
you be able to get to the
problem that the app has and be
able to solve that crash.  As
you can see with the app
developer, the first version
they uploaded had a lot of
issues.  As they kept releasing
new versions they fixed the
issue.  Then they with the final
version they just pushed, to
the Alpha beta channel,
identified two crashes and can
solve those.  developer in this
room would have a crash happen
in their app.  We decided to
launch the screen shot section,
which helps you with the
usability issues with your app.
This is powerful when you have
green results as part of the
prelaunch
port you can see what is looks
like across the different
versions, screen sizes and
languages.  You can see what
your app looks like in right to
left Arabic, merging markets,
Hindi, languages with long
strings.  German, there is an
issue with the layout of the
text.   your design team to be
able to catch the issues before
it is pushed to all the
users.  The last part is the
security section.  This is where
we push the security team to
put them to work for you.  This
is where we identify in the
application, and give you
information to be able to help
you solve that issue before you
release to all the users in
Play.  How to get access to this
prelaunch report?  You go to
the Google play developer
console, click on the prelaunch
tab, which replaced the precloud
test lab.  When you click on
the tab, opt in, the next UPK
upload will have this report
generated within one hour.  We
have already found that 60% of
the top apps on Google play used
the alpha beta c you didn't use
it before, now you have a
reason, thank you.  We will hand
it over to Ali to talk about
Firebase crash reporting.
Thanks everybody.  We launched
Firebase crash reporting today,
we're super excited.  Thanks for
being
here.  We believe that Firebase
Crash Reporting is a benefit.
While the prelaunch reports on
production stage, this focuses
on the stage of the users coming
into the app, interacting with
the app.  The objective is to
give them the best possible user
experience. is not exactly the
easiest thing, right.  When you
think about the mobile ecosystem
we live in, many variables at
play.  Multiple operating
systems, iOS levels, different
device manufacturer, device
model, the list of variables
goes on and on.  The combination
can be too much to handle
within testing alone.  need
something in production, losing
users that happened to be on a
device that wasn't tested or a
user path that wasn't accounted
for is not acceptable.  Every
user is as important as every
other user.  And that's exactly
why we introduce Firebase Crash
Reporting.  So what is it e
xactly?  It is an SDK that
support iOS and Android and you
get a package in your app, push
it to production and it detects
information about the errors
that your users see.  aggregates
this data and using the
Firebase console you can see
details about it so you can be
on the way to fixing the issues
faster than ever.  Setting up is
really easy.  If you are on
Android, grab the cradle plug i
n.  On iOS, install the pod, add
one line of code, off you go,
errors running.  When you push
to production and you start
seeing errors coming in, when
they first come in, they start
looking something like this,
right?  All over the place some
errors from some device, not
others.  Some errors from
specific user paths that weren't
accounted for.  And the first
thing we do with the data is we
cluster it.  So it looks
something like this.  We group
the errors by having them in
buckets of similar stacked
traces.  What that does for you
is a couple of things.  First of
all, it allows you to get a
sense of how many unique issues
you have in your app.  The other
thing is you have a sense of
prioritization.  You understand
for each cluster of errors, is
it a fatal error, nonfatal
error, you get a user count and
number of occurrences so you
understand the severity of the
issue.  friends
at sky scanner have been using
this for a while.  By using
clustering, they cut down on
issues and cut down on crashes
by 30%. Think about the amount
of gain you can have with such a
simple action.   So now you
have identified through
clustering what you need to work
on.  The best part now is
actually fixing the issue.  This
is where the Firebase console
comes in.  We give you a lot of
data, a lot of information,
everything you need to identify
the root cause of the issue and
get it done in no time.  The
first thing you see is a top
level breakdown of metrics.  So
we'll tell you obvious things
like the exception name in
Android or crashing scene in
iOS, but give you a breakdown of
the app version so you can
understand if the latest app
version in production is doing
better or worse than the
previous ones and the breakdown
of the operating systems or
operating system levels.
Breakdown of the devices and so
on.  The idea here is that you
are quickly able to attribute
the errors to some factors and
eliminate other factors.  The
next thing we give you is the
stat r give you the application
on iOS and Android, and you get
to see everything down to the
line number.  We highlight that
frame in the stat base that
belongs in your app so you can
jump to the problem and not
waste time.   you get
comprehensive device
diagnostics.  This is important
for a couple of things.  Let me
first tell you what you get.
Some of the things we give you
are the amount of ram and disk
space available on your device.
You get things like was the
device in landscape, portrait,
timestamp of the error, API
levels, basically everything
that is set on the device. You
can go through instances and see
what the device of that user
was like at the moment the error
took place.  is pretty
important, not just because you
get to fix the issue faster, but
you get to save time on
customer support, because you
don't have to do that back and
forth with the users so you
understand what the device was
like at the time of the error. I
have talked about so far is
about creating a snapshot,
accurate snapshot of the issue.
What happens when you have
multiple ways to lead you to the
same way in the code.  We have
a way to log custom errors --
custom events.  We out of the
box log some events like when
the crash takes place, but you
interlace your own custom events
with it, so you can read your
errors like a story. got some
data back, I populated my UI
model and boom, a crash happens.
becomes that much easier
over the last couple of months,
we had the opportunities to
work with Shazam.  They have
tested our product, given
feedback, made it much better.
Today I'm happy to have my
friend Iordanis who will tell us
about Android development.  He
will tell us about i Thank you.
Two points for pronouncing my
name correctly.you.  There is
excitement about Firebase.
Shazam that was excitement was
started when we received a
contact from the Shazam team.
installation was so easy, we
decided in some of the features
that were described and were
compelling, we decided to
integrate with crash reporting
first.  After a couple of months
of having it in production, it
turns out to be a valuable
production to our current tool
chain, that is for those three
reasons.   a very large number
of users per day.  Even if just
a tiny percentage of the users
experiences a crash, it adds up.
So the number of crashes are
actually quite a lot.  In our
previous system, couldn't handle
all of that traffic so we knew
we were not getting the whole
picture.  We know that will not
be an issue with Google, with
Firebase because it is powered
by the Google infrastructure and
we have an accurate view of how
many crashes we get.  Ali
described the level of details
with Firebase Crash Reporting. I
will give an example of how
that helped us.   we are getting
the number of users in the
distribution of users where the
crash occurs that we didn't have
before.  A couple of releases
ago, we resolved two new issues
that were appearing with the
same frequency but different
distribution to users.  The
first was spread out, high d
istribution.  We knew it wasn't
going to be a device specific
bug and quite occasional.  The
other one, on the other hand was
specific, limited number of
users.  When we went to the
Firebase console, we saw exactly
the manufacturer's models
affected, the iOS versions and
managed to fix the issues.  the
Firebase we integrated with
crash reporting, we use
analytics, we know it will be
part of the same unified STK in
the console.  We started using
dynamic links, as you may have
seen, helps you maintain the
context of the user through the
installation of your a amazing
to be an early using of crash
reporting and we look forward to
doing more and more
integrations.  Ali, back to
Thanks, pal.   I want to touch
on a point that he just
mentioned at the end.  One of
the main principleprinciples
that guide us as we think about
app quality is it is not just
about metrics shown on a
dashboard.  It is what you do
with this data and putting users
first by having timely reaction
and winning them.  We think
Firebase will be a key
ingredient to that.  you have an
e-Commerce app and you have a
feature that will help with the
conversion rates.  You want to
keep an eye on quality, of
course.  jump into the Firebase
console, first thing you do is
go to analytics.  In analytic,
build an audience of users that
see errors.  You can do this
because we have the integration
out of the box.  time it catches
an error. is added to an
audience.  We will see how
important this is in a bit.   is
go to remote config, which
allows you to control things
remotely.  You wire that to your
feature to use it as an on-off
switch.  You can pull the plug
anytime you want without having
to push an update.  Okay.  So
you do these two things, push
your new version out with a
feature, I take a look at the
crash reporting console.  And
all of a sudden, there is a
spike in errors.  Obviously, t
hat's not a good thing.  You
drill a bit more into it, look
at the stat base, you quickly
realize this has something to do
with the feature you just
pushed.  Jump back into remote
config, you turn the feature off
and go into Firebase
notifications, you can send a
push notification to an audience
in analytics.  You just created
an audience of people that see
errors and now you can
automatically send them a push
notification, tell them sorry,
you're working on this and maybe
send them a discount to re
engage them back to the app.
Within minutes, you would do
things that would otherwise take
you days of coding.  That is
not even counting the time to
get the update.  That is
powerful stuff.  At the end,
when you fix the issue, you go
back to test lab, build a test
case for it and make sure any
possible regression that might
happen in the future never makes
it to your users.  This is what
is cool about Firebase.  It is
14 powerful features that you
get access to using one SDK and
one console you mix and match
what you need.  They're a cross
platform, the vast majority of
features we have are supports
iOS and Android and only going
to get better as we
cross-integrate them more and
more.  We hope this gives you a
different perspective on app
quality and gets you to think a
bout it throughout the quality
of stages of your app. you
develop, use test lab to catch
all the bugs in development.
When you release, keep your eye
on the Alpha and beta channels
to make sure it is looking good.
production, use cross reporting
to catch everything out there.
We think using this combination
will go a long way and will get
you the five-star reviews.   We
hope you're excited we have an
amazing community of app
developers you can see on this
slide and would love nothing
more than for you to join us.
last notes here, we have a booth
set up right outside of this
room where the test lab team
actually set up a rack with
actual devices in it.  It is
really cool.  You need to check
this out.  So drop us a visit
over there.  will be around for
Q&A for about an hour or so. We
would love to talk to you.  F
inally, all the products we
talked about today are live
today.   the console, hack away,
enjoy it.  Keep thinking about
app quality.  It really matters.
Thank you so much.   to you in
a bit >> So we'll do Q&A, there
are mics here if you want to
ask questions right now,
actually.
does the automated espresso
work with asynchronous code like
an event bus or RX java
something that has the idling
resources? Yeah, so this is
definitely -- this is a great
question.  So this is one of the
scenarios that we're still
considering to support.  Like
one thing we're considering to
do isdo is add delays for that.
We know this isn't the optimal
way.  We generated a boiler
plate for fully functional
espresso code for you.  You can
hack at it or use it as is.
That is basically the idea.
Yeah.  Thanks.  Questions, just
come to the mic if you want to
ask a question.  Next question.
the Firebase Test Lab the
gentlemen at American Express,
is the idea to use it in the
continuous integration process
or more when you are ready to
release you send a bill up
there?  Is there a quick enough
performance to be able to go run
this and then be able to have
your check-in staged, based on
that.  Make sense?  Yeah, I
think, both are valid use case,
I think.  If you want to -- if
you have changes on a branch and
you want to make sure all your
tests are passing before the
branch is merged a CI is a great
place to do that.  You want to
make sure you do the regression
before you launch and also you
get the additional protection of
the Play launch report. Right.
But per check-in?   run every
branch before it gets merged so
whatever the latest check-in
when the CI picks it up.  If you
do a couple check-ins in a row,
it may miss one.  It is the
latest check in on every full
request.  You said it is
one single STK, have you made
any thoughts on how to make one
mass analytic STK.  Like Google
Play services.  I'm sure people
are concerned about that
cut depending on what you want.
In the case of iOS, you can
include individual fonts, but we
have configuration pods that
have a product for you as a base
package.  That is a preference
for you there.  lot of amazing
Hi, I was wondering how this new
mechanism is different from the
old crash reporting mechanism
where the user gets to select
what send details, screen shots
of the report and are the end
users aware of this change?  Do
you have control over it?  Yes.
So on the Google Play developer
console, you see crashes that
are reported by users for the
platform.  So these are crashes
ANRs, like exceptions.  The STK
is where you control your own
custom exceptions as well.  STK
will catch all the exceptions
that you control.  And then you
have the ANRs from Google play
show up as well.  We recommend
people to use Firebase Crash
Reporting as the crash reporting
tool moving forward to improve
your iOS and Android  Thank you.
Hello, I have two questions,
actually.  The first one, there
is a lot of Firebase branding.
Can we use it without Firebase
as a back end? >> Can you use
Firebase Crash Reporting without
using Firebase back end?
Definitely.  You can pick and
choose what you want to use.  No
matter what back end you can
use Firebase Crash Reporting.
we use Firebase test reporting
as a feedback tool so clients
can enter feedback not just
What sort It is not necessarily
a crash or issue, but something
behaving erratically.  Can they
bring up an interface and hey,
why is this happening?  That is
not something happening today,
but a feature request, and
something to link into your own
Hello.  I just want to know
about custom exceptions.  Can I
put some custom fields like user
I.D. or something and filter by
that?  I'm not sure I got the
question.  Can you say it again?
Can you put custom identifiers
with your crash, can you send
user I.D.s yourself?  We don't
have this at the moment.  It is
a top request.  working on it.
The problem with this is it has
implications on privacy of
course.  We want to do it in the
right way to protect end user
privacy.  We're aware of this
request and working on it as a
>> Okay, tyHi, our app uses the
camera.  It has always been hard
to test multiple devices. racks
like the lab offers when we
have this proprietary technology
that has to take frames and
understand what they're filming,
do you have any suggestions how
we can test something like
that?  Sure.  So one way to test
scenarios like this is to mock
the input to the camera and do
the processing.  If you do an
instrumentation testing, that is
one way to do it.  The thing
is, you can still use the
camera.  These are actual
phones, the fact is we tape the
back of the camera, because we
don't want any privacy concerns
from people looking at other
people's apps at the same time.
That is what we do.  Can you
get a set of frames to do any
processing for.  Like, do the
actual capturing of the screen
and mock the expected response
and do the processing  That is
one of the big advantages of
using the physical devices that
test lab has to offer, versus
using virtual d sounds like a
good idea, thanks.  But if I
want to test the output of the
camera itself, so there is no
possibility today on the lab,
right?  Yeah, but the idea is
like the camera itself, you
really -- it is depending on the
manufacturer.  Like you should
expect -- you should expect a
video at the end and your app
will perform as well as it will
be able to process that video.
So you can still make sure the
camera launches, it fires up, it
records something and then
separate the video processing
from that.  Basically, in t
esting, in general, you try to
breakdown every part.  Like, you
don't want to put as much
dependency -- so many
dependencies in your testing.
it down as much as possible.
That is one way to do it.  Break
it down, recording versus  y
have two questions for the
gentleman from
AMEX.  How big was the test
suite?  How long does it take
you to run it doing a PI  It has
grown over time, we're at well
over a thousand instrumentation
tests.  We break them up, we
shard them, meaning we don't run
them in one continuous, single
invocation, we run them in
multiple invocations to CTL.
will depend on how you run them,
like if you divide them up, how
you do that.  It depends -- it
will depend also on the QM time
on  In a typical VR verify
process how long does it take?
We can see 20 to 30 minutes,
which we also do code review.
The code review usually takes
longer than that.  But there is
a lot of  Did you think about
any cross back solutions.  I use
this for iOS and Android or
just Android?   A question for
the rest of the panel.  Do we
have successful examples of
folks that have used it for
cross  -- platform.  works
across iOS and Android.  We are
evaluating the iOS  When you
said Firebase is cross platform,
it is everything else Exactly,
except for test lab.  do you
have plans for doing that cross
platform?  That is a great  took
us like some significant effort
to bring this infrastructure up
and running.  So we're still
evaluating the iOS offering.
tuned for updates.   announce
right  Thank you.  All right.
We use apium to drive tests.  Is
that supported on the test lab?
If not, what is  Apium is not
supported in test lab.  Right
now the Android test link,
espresso and robotium.  And with
espresso test reporter, give it
a try, start hacking with
Thank yThanks.  I have a
question about the prerelease
testing.  Our app has a log-in
screen, you can't get past it
without logging in.  The issue
we have had with testing
currently on the console is you
get a log-in screen, it presses
around a little bit and that
finishes the testing.  Is there
plans to give simple log-in i
nformation?  Yes, one of the
gifts Ahmed demonstrated was
handling a log-in screen for
Google+ or any Google account, r
already supported today, if you
use a Google log-in for your a
pplication.   on other log-in
flows.  Today, the real value is
if you don't have a log-in, or
you have Google log-in with your
All right.  Thank  Thank you
very much.   have a question
about scaleability for test
labs.  two dimensions.  app is
quite popular in Kenya.  And we
have seen some pretty unique
devices and iOSOS versions on
it.  If that device is not in
test labs, how would we request
that?   since the announcement
today, I assume a lot of
developers are going to be
trying it out.  How do you
foresee scaling it to Google
scale as all the developers want
to run their test across all
the devices of your test lab?
That's a great question.  test
lab is trying to help you with
is the exact two points you m
ention.  It is something like
we're taking care of the
infrastructure so you don't have
to and we're taking care of
getting all the devices you need
so you don't have to.  It is
growing with Google scale, we're
building the infrastructure
with Google scale, you should
expect to get started and run it
right now.  In terms of device
diversity, this is top priority.
We're adding more devices now.
Just keep looking.  Hopefully
the devices that are popular in
Kenya will be available soon and
you will get more and more
value over  Thanks a lot,  Thank
yHi, everyone.  I have a
question directed to one of the
persons, Michael, who works in d
ynamics, how do you check a
feature called remote check
deposit?  Anything that is
remote check deposit?  related
the camera taking a picture?  We
haven't done any camera
testing.  The app we use on
Cloud Test Lab has no camera
features in it.  We haven't done
any camera  It doesn't support
it using espresso, right?
Because of third  You mean, like
you will can deposit a check in
the test?  Uh-huh. Yeah, as I
mentioned, one way to do it is
break it down into two parts.
Make sure the camera fires, that
is one test to account for.
The other part is when it gets
an image it is able to process i
is the recommended approach to
do  Thank you. Thanks.   do we
get those screen shots in the
developer console?  Are those
going to be kind of automatic?
Do we need to put in some test
code that tells you where to
take the screen s Yeah, so
today, the way it works is you
just upload the APK to the Play
developer console.  The robo
that Ahmed described will
interact with the app for about
five minutes.  There are screen
shots taken about every second
the robot is interacting.  We a
re adjusting it to capture the
big screen differences so it is
most valuable to you and
investigating other ways to
enhance that with showing you
the state the app is in.  You
should be able to gather the
data and shouldn't have to do
any work really.  Upload the amp
-- APK, the report is
generated for free.  to add to
what Fergus mentioned, if you
are using it to run the
implementation test, in
espresso, we have a library in
the documentation you can use.As
you mention you have to take
screen shots at the locations
you want, using that  how does
Firebase analytics compare to
Google analytics?  I think that
is something -- there is another
session on the analytics side
of things.  Maybe that would be
the right forum for that
question.  Unfortunately That
session was at 3:00 p.m., but I
can connect you with the person
for that.  work for a client
that is consider concerned about
the confidentiality, when you
capture the screen shots and
crash reporting, do you store
that, do you guys store that?
There is no screens shots in the
crash reporting.  These are
done in test lab and usually
dummy  Thank yHi, I know there
is
-- test lab is a developiented
--  platform.  is the role for
the developer in  The QA teams
spend time setting up the
devices and configuring the
cables, which is an inefficient
use of time. can go and run the
test and work on the automation
of the test and be able to go
through the results and actually
then generate the reports and
bugs of what issues are h
appening.  It is more about
enhancing the QA team's ability
to make the rest of the team
aware of the issues that are
being uncovered.   Thank you.
Ahmed do you want to reply to
that? >> Sure. For the QA team
question, the QA team can build
your infrastructure.  use case
here that is great for QA team
as well, previously from the
research, what we notice is
people will have a device
closet.  Before releasing a new
version, you grab a phone, run a
scenario and grab another
phone.  With the test recorder,
we want to make it easy.  Record
the script one, run it in the
cloud and make sure the app runs
on all the devices with one
trial of your app. >> Two
questions.  First, what is
average crash rate of the most
popular application?  is more
than crash and
features, and performance such
as STS and something like that.
Do you have any plan to test
this and improve the
performance?  Yeah, performance
testing is something definitely
where we have heard so many like
ideas and feedback about from
developers.  It is something we
will probably start thinking
about.  So yeah, stay tuned for
The first question is what is
average --Yeah, so in terms of
the previous question about the
confidentiality of app
developers, that is something
that we definitely respect.  we
wouldn't be able to tell you
which apps are the crashiest
ones, unfortunately. about
that.  there a standard for bad
crash rate or good crash >>
Yeah, definitely something we
could investigate is showing you
how you compare with your peers
in a way where it is anonymized
for the rest of the group.
Thanks for the feedback.  I
think we have time for one last
question.   the person behind
you?   All right.  So do you
have a way to test the look and
feel of the application rather
than like the functionality?
Yeah.  So as part of the p
relaunch report we show you the
screen shots.  Today, you
actually can look through the
screen shots and identify the
issues yourself, but definitely
things we are investigating is
accessibility and other
identification of the issues
that are appearing on the
screens. Okay.  then the app has
to be coasted in Firebase --
hosted in Firebase to be tested
or  Any Android app can  Got
You can choose to use one
Firebase offering.  it.  Thank
Thank you.  think we're out of
time now, but thanks everyone
for joining, encourage you to
use our quality >> Thank We
will hang out over there at the
test lab biography,  -- come by.
We will show you a demo as
of
. . .
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
***
Thi s text is being provided in
a realtime format. Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in  order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a  totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
Google
Google I/O
Angular two and Progressive Web
Apps
5:00 p.m.
May 18, 2016
5:00 p.m. PT
(Cheering and applause)
>> ROB WORMALD: Hey, I'm a
developer
advocate.
>> ALEX RICKABAUGH: I'm a
software
engineer. We work on
Angular mobile,
and we're here to talk about
progressive
web apps apps.
>> ROB WORMALD: So if you've
been
at I/O today, you heard  about
progressive
web apps. For us to understand
why
you should  be interested in
them,
them, we should go back a bit.
In
the Wild West  of the weapon
development
world, web development world,
six
months ago, this is how we
started
building web apps. You'd have a
browser,
a server, you'd  go to a
website.
The server would construct the
page,
send it  back, you decide to
buy
the budget widget, you send a
post
back, and the  cycle would go
on
and on.
And this worked really great for
a
long time.
>> ALEX RICKABAUGH: And then we
discovered
Ajax and started  building
single-page
applications. The idea was
instead
of a  request response cycle
over
and over again, we would send
down
JavaScript code with the first
page.
That code would take over  and
run
the UI. If it needed data, it
would
get it. We would send  back
JSON
and drop it. This was a much
better
world, actually. We  had
applications
that felt a lot more
interactive
and faster.
>> So the framework that we work
on
came from this world. You
might
have heard of it. Anybody here
an
Angular developer? Yes.  You
can
woo, that's good. So, we de
scribe
Angular as this super  heroic
JavaScript
framework. It's like what
Angular
would've been been, or, it's
what
HTML would have been had we
designed
it for  web apps. There's tons
of
Angular apps in the wild.
Everything was wonderful and
great.
It's a great world we live  in.
>> So we started building more
and
more complicateed single-
single-page
applications with features and
bells
and whistles. We  ran into some
problems,
right. Suddenly we're pushing a
lot
of  code to the browser, every
time
the application starts up. The
web
wasn't designed to do this. Web
pages
are supposed to be  interactive
.
It shouldn't take ten seconds
to
load the code in.
>> This is why we're here today,
and
why this has become a  thing.
This
is the quote from Google
developers
website. I'm not  going to read
it
to you. But the primary
takeaway
here is the  idea of the app-
like
user experience. On the age
team,
Angular team, we've  been
trying
to hit the goal of building app
-like
apps, right? So  while the web
has
been evolving, while these
ideas
of PWAs are  coming out,
Angular
has been evolving. We've been
writing
the new  version of Angular,
Angular
2, and we've been really kind
of
trying to re-evolve the entire
framework
as this whole web thing
changes.
We want to keep up, right?
And so to do that, we wanted to
build
one. We wanted to see  what the
experience
was like. A huge amount of the
Angular
team  doesn't build apps on a
day-to-day
basis. We build framework code
code.
We don't always know what you
as
developers have to deal  with.
So
this is something we want to do
.
So we wanted to build  this
progressive
web app and get a feel for what
it
means to make  an application
really
perform, what it means to make
them
re reliable offline, online,
how
hard it is, how easy it is to
make
things immerseive to get this
good
experience.
>> We didn't just want to build
another
sample application. We  wanted
to
build something we would use.
The
Angular team, we get  a lot of
GitHub
issues. Some are good bug
reports,
reproduceleproducible
reproducible,
and some are not as high
quality.
We need a way to  triage them
quickly.
We built issue zero. If you
used
inbox zero,  it's kind of the
same
principle. You go through and
swipe
left on  issues to close them.
You
swipe right to triage and apply
labels.
As Rob was saying, we don't
build
comprehensive applications
that
much. We wanted tomore all of
make
sure this stuff would work well
together.
We took the idea of an
application
shell, the service  worker API,
fire-based
authentication, it's a server
less
app. We  used index DB to make
sure
the data is cacheed offline. If
you
don't have a network
connection,
it'll load. We used two
projects
within Angular, our material
framework
for building pretty,  beautiful
UIs,
and our CLI which takes care of
a
lot of the  build tooling for
us.
So the first challenge we wanted
to
see if we addressed well  was
loading
the application, getting
something
on the screen  really quickly.
And
so, this idea of application
shell
that we're  using to do this
comes
from progressive web apps. The
idea
is  that you really take
advantage
of what index.HTML is. It's not
just
a place where we put the
scripts
to load and the link tags  to
the
CSS. It's the very first thing
that
gets sent from the web  server
to
the phone or to the browser.
So we take advantage of it and
we
put this static UI into it.
This
code that will render this
little
title bar and a menu icon.  And
it's
not much, but it tells our user
s
this application is a alive on
the
page. It's loading. It's
working.
It's doing work  for you in the
background
to fetch data. At the very
bottom,
we  put our script tags loaded
asynchronously.
And that means that  Angular is
loading
in the background while the
browser
is busy  rendering this page.
Eventually
it'll fill this application
shell
with dynamic content.
And that gives you a really nice
,
beautiful loading experience
experience.
But one challenge doing this is
you
kind of have two  copies of
your
application. You have the
static
code, the HTML  that loads the
snap
shell, and then you have your
dynamic
application written in Angular
.
We didn't want you to have to
do
this. So we thought, ha what
if
we could use the same
primitives
in  Angular that we use to
control
what DOM appears where, to
what would be in your
application
shell and would be in your
static --
in your dynamic application.
So that's what we did. We have
this
little shell render  directive.
And
you can apply it and say this
thing
should be part  of the app
shell,
or excludeed from the app shell
.
>> So how do we do this? If
you've
built an Angular 1  application
,
you know the point of Angular.
The
idea has been to  write an
application,
talk to Angular, and Angular
handles
talk talking to the DOM. We
don't
make you do manual DOM updates.
This
has been the selling point,
it's
why we use it. But it's also
kind
of the biggest crutch in
Angular 1,
we are tightly coupleed  to the
idea
of splitting the two  ideas
apart.
So now Angular 2 is very much
two
parts.
So we have the Angular that you
kind
of know and love, you  speak to
,
that's what your application
talks
to. Then we have a  separate
layer
we call the renderer, which
talks
to the DOM. But  these two
pieces
were decoupled. We have a
bridge
you speak  between the two. And
it
means this renderer could be by
default,
the one we use in the DOM like
in
Angular 1, but it allows us to
do
flexible, interesting things. A
lot
of this work is under a
project
called Angular Universal. The
idea
of Universal is that  it allows
us
to do -- really boot up your
application
and treat  Angular as if it was
just
an app.
You don't have to think it's a
browser
or web app or whatever,  it's
just
an app. And so, this is an
example
in Gulp. We're  booting up your
application,
pre-rendering the content, and
writing
it out to disk. So this is
happening
when you build your  app at the
same
time you're compileing your
code.
We can take that  application
shell,
do all of the work upfront, and
then
you can  statically cache this
application
ready to go on your web server.
>> That's how Universal works to
build
application shell from  your
templates
in HTML at build time. But you
can
actually run  Universal at run
time,
too, on your web server. If you
have
a no  JS server or ASP.net has
a
beautiful integration, when the
user
requests a page, instead of
serveing
them the JavaScript and the
HTML
and having Angular run in the
browser,
you can run Angular  in the
server
and render out the HTML that
you
would otherwise  have displayed
in
the browser and send it to the
user
statically.
So here's an example of how that
works
in a no JS server.  You've
probably
seen Express, a framework for
building
web  servers in node. And here
we're
telling express when it sees a
request
for an HTML file, it should use
the
express engine from  Universal.
Instead
of sending static HTML bytes to
the
client, Ex Express will boot up
Angular application, run
through
and  render all your templates
just
as if it were running in the
browser,
and send the HTML to the client
.
It's a powerful way of  doing
things.
And it has a lot of benefits. We
talked
about performance,  getting
applications
on screen fast. But another one
is
search  engine optimization.
Not
every web crawler out there
executes
JavaScript code when it's
loading
your application. So if you
want
to be indexed well and have a
good
experience in search  engines,
it's
beneficial to be able to serve
static
HTML to the  crawler instead of
a
bunch of JavaScript that it
won't
understand.
And that also works on social
networks.
If someone takes a  link to
your
application and shares it, the
scraper
from the  social network is
trying
to figure out a good image or
text
ex extract to put in the post.
It
won't know what to do with the
JavaScript,
but it can understand the
static
HTML that Universal  produces.
So
this experience with Universal,
rendering
on the  server, works really
well
across all browsers, all device
s.
But if your user happens to be
using
a modern web browser like
chrome
that supports service worker,
this
experience gets even  better.
You
can think of a service worker
as
an HTTP serveer that  runs in
the
browser and handles all the
requests
clientside. So,  in the service
worker
we can cache all of the static
content
for  your application, the
JavaScript,
CSS, HTML that makes it tick.
Whenever
the user opens the app, we're
not
serveing over a network
connection
slowly, we're loading it from
cache
on the phone.
In addition to the static
content,
we cache that application
shell
that was built for you by
Universal
at build time so that  even the
very
first paint running locally
happens
with static  content. And that
is
really fast.
>> It's crazy fast.
>> So that only gets us so far,
right?
We can get the initial  load.
The
initial first paint working
really
quickly. But Angular  still has
to
download in the background, and
your
application  still has to
download
in the background. And that
means
we can't  be doing things like
this,
where we just load too much
JavaScript
code before the application can
start
up. And so how  do we deal with
this
problem? We break up the
application
and use  the router to load
code
in only when it's needed.
So when we start up the app, we
only
serve the code needed to
render
the home screen. If you were
watching
the keynote, android  instant
apps
works the same way, only serve
ing
the part of the app  needed for
the
first view. As you move around
in
the application,  our router
will
issue a request and load in
code
dynamically to  keep the
application
running. And that, too, gets
even
better if  you have a service
worker.
Not only do we cache the static
content
in the application shell, for a
small
application, we can  load all
the
routes into the service worker
cache
so that they're  available just
as
if the user had downloaded your
whole
app.
For a large application, we plan
to
have some strategies in  the
service
worker to wait for a strong
Wi-Fi
connection and wait  for the
user
to be idle in the application,
and
then start pre- pre-fetching
some
of these things more
intelligently.
And we  think that'll lead to a
really
good experience for all sizes
of
applications, no matter how
much
JavaScript you need.
>> So, again, I think we've
solved
or maybe not solved, but  made
progress
on getting this application run
ning
quick. And,  again, being able
to
progressively load this
application
as we go  along. And data bind
ing
is the magic that makes Angular
tick.
It's the big reason we all use
it.
If you haven't, we'll do a
quick
review. This is what it looks
like
in Angular 2. We have a
template,
data in the controller, and
binding
this repo to iCop  to the
source
tag of the image, and doing
double
curly braces and  just doing
some
actual text binding there.
So this is really fast,
something
Angular has done for a long
time.
It's why we all love it, right?
And
I think, too, we've  made
changes
to how the change section works
.
In an Angular 1  application,
you
could get into situations where
if
you were  doing estrange things
,
strange things, you'd get a
cycle.
If you had an Angular
application
that explodeed and said
infinite
digest psych, cycle, this is
why.
In Angular 2, we wanted to
solve
the problem. Change  connection
runs
from top to bottom -- change
detection.
We start  checking at the top,
run
it down,. Run it once, it's
very
fast.
But if you have a situation
where
you have a huge list, a
thousand
GitHub issues to get through in
your app, you can get  into
situations
where you get bogged down. You
have
a lot of  stuff that has to be
change
detected. We put an
optimization
in  here that we called on push
change
detection. And this allows us
to,
in this case, we have an issue
list.
This is going to have a  lot of
stuff
in it. You might be doing other
in the  application that's not
going
to change that often.
You don't want to have to repeat
edly
check the bindings. We  can
declare
this on push change detection
strategy.
What it means  is that when the
application
does its regular change
detection
cycle, we skip the whole tree
of
components. It gives you a big
boost
in speed. If you're using
observables
or anything like that that, you
can
then say to the application,
hey,
this thing is  ready to be
dirty
checked. You get a nice
performance
boost from  doing that.
So, bear with me, this gets
technical.
This is my favorite  part of
Angular
2. In Angular 1, we did this
idea
where you took  your template
and
the way data binding works is
we
compile your  templates. We
load
them in, pull them off the
server,
run code in  the browser that
parses
these templates, and turn them
into
introductions  introduction
instructions
to update the DOM. It works
really
well. But we want wanted in
Angular
2 Angular 2 to make sure we did
it
better.
So in Angular 2 we have a very
similar
idea. We have the idea  where
we're
takeing your templates and
generateing
these  instructions from them,
but
doing it at build time rather
than
in  the browser when your
application
boots up. We do it when you
build
the app with web pack or
whatever,
and we generate very,  very
efficient
code. To bias calls
it obviously
fast, which is a  good term you
get
good benefits. It's fast. You
don't
have to  ship weight to the
browser.
Things start up quickly. We got
the
demo working the other day day.
This
is a hello world application.
So,
I believe it's  broughtly com
pressed,
an Angular 2 application where
we
have to  ship this extra code,
it
gets down do 118K, which isn't
bad.
If  we can pull out the extra
code,
we can get it down to
22kilobytes 22kilobytes,
which is ridiculously small.
>> Isn't Angular 1 around
50?
>> It's bigger than that.
>> Rob loves running the
offline compiler
and figureing out how  small he
can
get it.
>> This is my life.
>> ALEX RICKABAUGH: This is my
native
favorite part. We have  Angular
running
in dynamic mode. We're shipping
the
compiler to  the browseer,
downloading
templates, and running the
compilation
step there. It's not a bad
experience
for developing an  application.
You
can edit code on disk, save it,
refresh,
it  shows up in the browser.
It's
great. But we have this big
green
blob here. I can't see the
screen.
This big green blob is Angular
compileing
your application, all the work
that
we have to do, all  the
execution,
before your app boots up.
We finally finish compilation,
there's
a pink ribbon. That  works
today.
With the offline compiler, we
get
rid of the big  green blob.
We're
no longer downloading the
compiler
and running  it. We don't have
to
do that work. When the browser
loads
the  JavaScript that the off
line
compiler produces, it runs your
app
from the first line. It just
works.
It's a lot faster. We don't
even
have to do the work in the
browser
of parseing the  JavaScript
from
the compiler.
And that gives you even more
speedup.
So, here the dynamic
application
loads in about 500 milliseconds
,
and whatever this  trace was
captureing,
we're booting the static,
compileed
version  in about 250. So it's
a
really good speed improvement.
>> ROB WORMALD: We've done a
huge
amount of work. We've done
some
really good stuff. One of the
big
things we are exciteed on  the
team
is now everybody else can start
building
stuff on top of  this. The
reason
Angular 1 was such a success is
we
had a huge  community of people
who
built awesome tools. For us,
it's
now the  time to see the cool
stuff
come. If you watched the
keynote,
there was a big deal with Fire
Base.
Whoo. We worked with them  for
a
long time. They've been amazing
partners.
If you've used Angular Fire and
Angular 1,
awesome library. We  wanted to
make
sure there was a better
experience
for Angular 2.
We have Angular Fire 2,
it works on their realtime
database.
It's  awesome. It's a single
thing
you drop in your application.
This
is a realtime chat and eight
lines
of code. A very simple thing
to
do. It's amazing, part of the
Fire
Based umbrella.  Authentication
is
super hard for web developers,
super
hard for  everybody, right?
In Angular Fire, we drop it in.
Two
bits to config, plug in  your
application,
and then it's two lines of code
,
log in, there  you go. Super,
super
simple. The other thing that
comes
into Fire  Based is push
messageing,
cloud messageing. So we've
never
been  able to do this in a
browser
before. Native apps can do it.
We've
never had this possibility in
a
web browser before.
Now with service workers,
they're
running in the background
constantly
all the time. If you have
access
to a service worker,  you can
tell
it to register for push
notifications.
Even if the  application is
closed,
you get a push notification.
It's
amazing  stuff. This, we're
super,
super exciteed about. The other
one
that  we're really super excite
ed,
and they talked about this, Ion
ic
has  been an amazing partner.
Hundreds
of of thousands of Ionic apps
out
there.
They do a really good job of
doing
visuals, apps in general.  They
announceed
that they're going to support
progressive
web apps apps. We've been
working
with them for a little while on
building
Ionic progressive web apps.
That's
going to be super, super
exciting.
Stoked about that. And this is
one
thing that if you're  a
JavaScript
developer, this is mind-blowing
.
And if you write code in any
other
language, you're like,  why're
you
talking about this. But, if
you're
a JavaScript  developer, I want
to show this to you. This is
Angular
2. We use  type script. Now we
have
code that understands itself
effectively effectively.
This is me getting code
appreciation
in my completion in my IDE. I
was
like, I'm a web developer, I
don't
get this. When I screw up, I
get
warnings before you compile
your
code or run it, it's like  you
did
something wrong. This is a big
deal.
If you're an Android developer,
you're
like why're you talking  about
this?
Because we don't get this. We
don't
get to do this.  This, I think,
is
super, super amazing. This is
coming
for us.
>> The offline compiler
generates
type script. You will get
error
messages saying you misspelled
something
in this data bind binding, it
doesn't
exist on your component.
>> I spent 30 minutes going,
what
have I broken in the  compiler?
It
was telling me, no, there's
something
wrong in your  template. I had
no
idea. This has never happened
that
your  template is checked and
it
said, you're wrong, do that.
That's
coming soon. Very, very cool.
>> You're write Angular
components,
and that works really well
well.
But there's this thing called
web
components, and it's  basically
a
custom DOM element that you
make
and attach some  behavior to.
And
because they're normal DOM
elements
and Angular  works well with
all
DOM elements, they fit really
well
into an  Angular application.
So
this is a YouTube search page
we've
written. It has an input where
we
want to type for something, and
a
list of search results, and a
YouTube
player.
And the player is not an Angular
component.
It's a web  component that
someone
has written that takes a video
ID.
We  Biden the ID bind  the ID
to
the one that comes out of the
search
and it works. It's  awesome.
So we've
talked about type script, about
the
compiler,  and in general, the
JavaScript
ecosystem is getting complicate
ed complicated.
Angular works with ES6 modules
now.
There's all  kinds of
compilation
steps uh you have to do. We
wanted
to build  something to get that
out
of your way and let you focus
on
building applications.
That's what our CLI is designed
to
do. It lets you focus on  your
app
and we take care of the tooling
.
To start a new project  with
the
CLI, you MPM install it. We're
used
to doing stuff like  this. You
say
NG new my web app. It will set
up
an application  with a build
script.
When you seed in and say NG
serve
it'll  build your application,
it'll
start up a web browser, set up
a
web server, open the app in
the
browser, and actually watch the
file
system. So when you edit code
in
your IDE and save it it'll  re
fresh
the browser and start executing
.
So if you want to start doing
mobile
app development with  Angular,
we've
added this dash dash mobile
flag
to the CLI. When  you say NG
new
dash dash mobile we set up the
same
Angular  application scaffold
and
add a web app manifest so you
get
a nice  install to home screen
prompt
in Chrome. I think we add meta
tags
for safari as well. If you
want
to, it'll set up a service work
er
so you can do do -- your
application
will be reliable to work off
offline
or online.
It's integrateed with the build
process
to figure out the  static
information,
it'll be cacheed, we set up the
application
shell for you with Universal
so
you can use the shell, render,
shell,
no render, and it'll generate
an
application shell for you you.
So
our CLI is not only designed to
help
you start up a  project, but
also
to live with you as you go
through
the  development process. It'll
create
your project, install
dependencies,
help you scaffold your
application.
Every time  you're creating new
components,
or creating new routes or
something
like that, it'll set up the
boiler
plate for you.
It'll help you at build time run
the
compilation process,  generate
service
workers and manifests, helps
you
run tests, do C CSS processing.
When
you're ready to deploy to
something
like  Fire Based hosting, CLI
has
integration for that. It lives
with
you throughout the development
process.
>> So this is the thing that is
very,
kind of, interesting and and,
kind of, crazy to eplain. I love
explain.
We've optimizeed everything we
can
in Angular 2. But we are still
kind
of at this disadvantage to
native
apps. You know, they have the
ability
to take advantage of  the whole
application,
kind of, power. They've got
multiple
processors in mobile devices
now.
As web developers, we're Yoo
you
have had used  to working in
one
thread, shareing it with all
the
work the  browser has to do,
pointing,
point painting, rendering. The
idea
of multi-thread multi-threaded
web
apps is crazy. We've had web
workers
for a  long, long time.
But you've probably never used
them.
Some people do, but, Jr.,  very
few
people take advantage of them
in
their applications. And  this
is
because they're really, really
hard
to work with. You  have to
start
up a script in the background.
And
then you're re remote control
ling
your application over this tiny
pipe.
It's  hard to work with. Nobody
uses
them. It's a shame because we
have
all this power waiting to be
unlocked.
So, again in, in Angular 2 we
wanted
to taking advantage of this
.  The
same tech that lets us do rend
ering
and application shell  actually
allows
us to do something really
interesting.
So we can  take your Angular
application,
we can move the whole thing,
all
of your code in Angular, into
a
web worker, and then we run a
very,
very light weight rendering
thread.
Your main DOM thread  has a
tiny
listener that talks to the DOM
and
listens to eventses eventses,
events,
and transfers everything to
Angular
running, effective
ly, in the  background.
Rather than the life cycle look
ing
like this, where the code  is
doing
work, shareing, and competing
for
resources with the rest  of the
browser,
we can split it up. This means
your
application  gets to work free
form
in the background and the main
UI
thread  is kept really, really
clean
just for render, paints, and
the
things the browser needs to do
.
This gives you incredible
performance.
This is experimental.
This may not be right for every
app,
but really, I think the  point
of
this for us is that we want to
be
sure that for the next  five or
ten
years, whatever comes down the
pipeline
in the  browser, we're flexible
.
And I think that this is the
beginning
of something very, very
interesting
from Angular. So this is kind
of
close to the end of our talk,
but
the point we want to get
across
is that this is really just the
beginning
for Angular 2.
We're just coming into our re
lease
candidate. Go try it out.  We
want
to see what you guys build with
it.
I think it's going to  be
really
exciting. The whole progressive
idea,
there's been a  lot of talk
about
it. It's a really, really
amazing
concept for  the web. We want
to
make that as easy as possible
for
everybody  to get started.
>> One of the things I've heard
people
say is progressive web  apps
are
really good normal apps that
get
super powers and  browsers that
have
all this functionality. Angular
is
the super  heroic JavaScript
framework.
We think they go perfect
together.
>> Cool. So, if you want to
check
out our code, issue zero is
open
source. We have the GitHub repo
here. If you want to learn
more
about the service worker and
application
shell, the content  is here.
And
tomorrow there is a talk by
jewels
jewel Jules, at 4:00 p.m.
tomorrow.
So, make sure to check it out.
(Applause)
(Cheering and applause)
>> And we'll hang around for
questions
if anybody has any.
>> Yeah,.
>> So feel free to step up.
>> Questions? No questions?
>> Not a single question. No one
even
wants to ask when  Angular 2 is
going
to be released?
(Laughter)
>> Somebody's got to ask that
question,
come on.
>> Shoot.
>> When will Angular 2 be
released?
>> Good question. Soon.
(Laughter)
>> AUDIENCE: Good answer.
>> PRESENTER: So the real answer
to
that question, I should  talk
about
this while I'm in front of a
bunch
of Angular  developers. The
core
of it, I think we're pretty
stoked
that it's  fully baked. I think
the
router we're pretty sure is not
fully
baked. I don't think anybody
in
this room is going to argue
with
me on that. Angular 2 Angular
core is ready to go. We would
probably
almost ship it tomorrow, but
we
want to make sure that the
router
and everything is going to
work
really, really well with it.
So everybody else on the Angular
team
is in the office right  now
writing
the router. That's why they're
not
on stage with us  here. As soon
as
we're happy that that's ready
to
go, it'll be  out to go. But
the
core itself is stable, if you
want
to start  writing components
and
all the stuff we've talked
about,
it's  good to go.
Do you want to
use the mic? I'm sorry. There's
a
whole queue of people waiting,
actually.
But ask yours quickly. I
apologize.
We're really bad at this. Sorry
.
>> AUDIENCE: Is it 22 KBs?
>> PRESENTER: That's a real
number.
>> AUDIENCE: So then it's much
smaller
than React, as well. So  how
does
it handle all the DOM structure
?
How does it get to know  that
something
has changed if it does not --
does
the architect  architect --
>> PRESENTER: Sure. There's a
couple
ways it works. The idea  of
this
tiny number is that Angular is
modular,
for a start. Most  of the code
that's
in Angular itself is this idea
of
takeing code  and generating
DOM
from it. It's all the mechanism
that
has to  parse your templates.
Hello
world at 22K means we've
stripped
out  everything that's not
involved
in basically just, like,
getting,
sort of, data onto the DOM.
And things like zone -- zone is
what
listens to events and  triggers
this
step. The way you can think
about
it is that in  dynamic mode, we
generate
or have all this code around
that
does  the translation. In
static
mode, we drop the code and
generate
the code we need to do the
updates
for the specific views. Does
that
answer your question? You're
shakeing
your head like no.
>> AUDIENCE: So the time you
were
showing, that does not come  at
the
end of the second time? The
content
loaded fully. It'll  still,
like,
process because it's got some
things
to get, will it  be showing? Is
the
content fully loaded at that
point
in time?
>> PRESENTER: Yes.
>> AUDIENCE: It is? So how does
it
get the stuff?
>> PRESENTER: Oh. So the idea is
,
when we run this compilation
pipeline,
we do something called tree-
shakeing.
And what that does  is look at
what
code is used in the application
and
what code is  not. So Angular
has
a lot of features in it. You
probably,
in a  single application, will
not
manage to use all of them. We
want
to make sure that we're not
sending
code to the browser that's
never
going to run. So that's why
that
number is so small. We've
taken
out the cop compiler, we did
compilation
already. You're not  using
forums,
we've taken out HTTP and router
and
all that.
That's why the number is really
small.
It's only the code  that's need
ed
to get that done. As you build
more
complicateed  apps, you'll
touch
more of Angular, we'll bring
more
code in.  You're only paying
the
cost of the bytes that you're
actually
going to use.
>> If that didn't answer your
question,
find us after and  we'll talk
about
it, for sure.
>> AUDIENCE: Did I understand
you
correctly regarding the  multi-
threading,
you were saying it's similar to
the
app frame framework, the
application,
or is it different?
>> PRESENTER: I mean, it is your
same
Angular application, but  we
started
in a slightly different manner.
>> AUDIENCE: How you set up the
time
slices for the threads,  and
the
context switching, is it
similar
to the context switching  in
the
application?
>> PRESENTER: There is some
context
switching that goes on.
>> AUDIENCE: How do you set up
the
timers to --
>> PRESENTER: Again, so this is
not --
the analogy to the way  a
proper
multi-thread environment, it's
not
exactly the same.  We're still
doing
this message passing between
two
queuetion, but but, it's dis
patching
render instructions out and get
ting
it back  in. We're not sink
synchronizeing
application work.
>> Your Angular app is running
in
the web worker, doing change
connection
detection, making requests,
running
your normal application.
>> AUDIENCE: This is not
something
the developer can tune?
>> PRESENTER: No. It's sort of
like,
the entire application --
instead
of booting it in the main UI
thread,
you boot it in the  background.
>> AUDIENCE: Those who code size
s
you showed, one of them was  22
K,
the other one was 116. The 22K,
that's
the complete size of  the image
,
or as you scroll down or click,
then
more corrode code will be
downloaded?
>> PRESENTER: It's like an
Angular
binary doing the bare  minimum.
Take
some data and render it to the
screen.
That's the  point. It's an
Angular
application that is doing the
my
malthing the minimal of  what
Angular
does. It's a complete
application.
There's no other  code to be
loaded.
That's the whole package.
>> AUDIENCE: Thank you.
>> PRESENTER: Yeah,.
>> AUDIENCE: I also had a
question
about the multi-threaded  thing
you
talked about at the end there.
>> PRESENTER: Sure.
>> AUDIENCE: What is the
advantage
to having a separate render
thread
on the main thread and running
the
application in the web  worker?
You're
still running your whole
application
from a single  thread, still
push
updates to the renderer in the
same
amount of  time.
>> PRESENTER: This is a good
question.
There's a cool demo you  should
watch.
I'll give you the link after
this.
You still have  the same amount
of
work to do. We're not changing
that
problem.  In a web application,
when
you do something like, lets say
apply
an image  filter, like on
Instagram,
if you do that work in a single
thread thread,
that work's going to run but
everything
else is going to  stop.
You're not going to be able to
scroll
the page. Everything  freezes
while
that work happens.
>> You click the button and it
doesn't
release until the work  is done
.
The browser is blocked waiting
on
your application.
>> So what your user sees is
this
horrible stoppage. The
important
thing with the progressive idea
is
that we never want  the browser
to
go janky, we never want the
user
experience to  suffer.
Splitting
these two things up allows us
--
they could  keep scrolling the
page
while this work is turning in
the
background. That's the general
theory
of this. Does that make  sense?
>> AUDIENCE: Thank you.
>> PRESENTER: Cool.
>> AUDIENCE: You know this guy,
he's
awesome.
>> PRESENTER: A little bit.
>> AUDIENCE: I was saying that I
am
going to be able to write  a
single
code base with Ionic, push to
progressive,
Android and  iOS eventually?
>> PRESENTER: That's the general
theory.
Adam is nodding his  head yes,
he's
from the Ionic team, you should
talk
to him.  Actually, to get into
a
bigger discussion, the coolest
thing
about Angular's dependency
injection
is that you can write an
application
and think about the top layer
of
it. For things like  native
storage
and database and whatever, use
DI
to swap out  these pieces. 90%
of
your code base should be
portable
between  the different contexts
and
that last 10% you should be
able
to  change out with whatever
environment.
>> AUDIENCE: Fire Based
underneath.
>> PRESENTER: Yes, beautiful.
>> AUDIENCE: Does Angular have
any
support for data stream,  like
data, continuous flow?
>> PRESENTER: You asked the
right
guy.
>> This is Mr. Stream.
>> AUDIENCE: Socket IO, or
something,
how does it render such?
>> PRESENTER: So. That's a good
question.
We showed you Fire  Based on
stage.
There's nothing opinionated,
most
people use  Socket IO. We don't
provide
a library, but you can pull the
one
off NPM and it works. This is
the
nice thing about Angular 2.
It's
less opinionated than Angular 1
.
It should work. Socket IO,  web
socket,
signal, all these other things,
just
plug it in and  it works.
>> AUDIENCE: Awesome.
>> AUDIENCE: Hi. Will the pre-
compileed
templates become like a  JSX,
like
a language in the future?
>> PRESENTER: That's -- so.
(Chuckling)
JSX, tricky question,  right?
Conceptually,
the output of pre-compilation
is
on a high  level not dissimilar
to
what the output of JSX looks
like.
It's a  set of render
instructions.
I don't want to compare then
one
to  one, but, I don't think you
will
ever write the code that our
compiler
is writing, right? And I think
that
at the end of the  day, the
language
for describeing JSX, we have a
very
different  opinion. There's a
good
blog post which is like, we
like
templates because they're a
limiting
thing.
You're not writing this other
language.
They're simple,  declarative,
we
can do what we need to do. JSX
is
a different  opinion. It's not
wrong,
bad, or worse, but it's a
different
way  of thinking about things.
>> A big part of that is we can
optimize
them.
>> I probably shouldn't say this
,
but, I think the live stream
is
off. If you wanted to write a
JSX
renderer for Angular 2, you
could
do it. We're not going to, but
you
could.
>> AUDIENCE: The example you
gave
during the talk, that the
templates
compile into type script gave
me
the idea that you can  basic
ally
then do runtime, like checking
as
well, writing the  HTML. You
can
say, this is wrong.
>> PRESENTER: That's exactly
what's
coming down the pike.
>> We have mature code in
Angular
2, code that has existed for  a
while
now that we've run through this
new
process and it  catches bugs.
>> AUDIENCE: Perfect.
>> PRESENTER: It's amazing.
>> You can think of it like the
template
becomes the source  map for the
generateed
code.
>> AUDIENCE: Thank you.
>> AUDIENCE: What's the
relationship
between Angular 2 and  Polymer?
I've
seen that. It's another
component
library.
>> PRESENTER: Again, I think
probably
different opinions on  the way
to
do things. Neither is right or
wrong.
One of the cool  things about
Polymer
components is you can drop them
in
Angular  apps. That's the short
answer.
We are two different frameworks
that
look at the world slightly
differently.
>> AUDIENCE: How would you
characterize
your opinion and their  opinion
?
I assume you're friendly.
>> PRESENTER: Yeah,. I would say
I
think their main focus is on
DOM
and components as a thing,
right.
And very much if you like  web
platform.
And I think that our focus is
very
much on building  larger
applications
on really JavaScript, right.
And
I think  that's a fair thing to
say,
right? We have different
opinions
on  dependency injection and
the
way you compos things.
>> And running in locations
other
than browsers, like the  server
.
>> We play with our stuff their
stuff
a lot. It's an interesting idea
.
We like the idea of dropping
Polymer
components in Angular apps.
>> Before Angular 2 material
came
out, I was building a sample
application
and just took the Polymer
material
library and import imported it
wholesale
and it worked. It was beautiful
.
>> PRESENTER: Yeah,. Cool. Any
other
questions? No? Okay. Well,
thanks
for coming.
>> PRESENTER: Yeah, thank you
very
much.
(Cheering and applause)
(Session
concluded at 5:39 p.m. PT)
(This text is provided as a
realtime service and is not to
be  copied from any live event.
Please contact Caption First if
you  would like to receive a
properly formatted transcript of
this  event.)
the
F
product ideas using Firebase.
Product Ideas Using Firebase
[Cheers]
All right.  This is going to be
something that you will
remember, I
think.  Hello, everybody my name
is Ran.  I work on Google.  I
spend most of my time on L
aunchpad.  That is an a start
with Google Developer.  Mainly,
I will talk about common
challenges related to the
never-ending question of: What
should we build next?  I will
share with you some best
practices that we know are
working for startups and how we
can leverage Firebase to
use them.
In 2015, we worked with 6,000
startups worldwide and provided
50,000 hours of one-on-one
mentorship. >>
Yeah!  Now, for those 50,000
hours of mentorship, we have
learned what drive startup
success and what doesn't.  works
and what doesn't work.  Now, we
know that startups are not the
same.   say all startups are the
same, but there are common
problems and challenges that
every startup needs to solve.
there is the technical
challenge.  Can we build it?
is the product challenge.  All r
ight, we can build it, do people
need it?   use it?  Next there
is the market challenge.  All
right, we build it, there is
people who need it, we want to
use it, can we reach them?  It
is not that trivial.  First
challenge is the scale
challenge.  When you think about
it, startup scales are any
aspect of user, employees,
operations and how do you do
that and maintain your sanity.
but not least, the financial
challenge.  How do you make it
profitable, make money in your
startup, your business.  Today I
will focus on the product
challenge.  I like to call it,
how to build products that
people need, that people
actually use.   usually, when I
talk about the product
challenge, people automatically
think that it's related only to
early stage startups, to teams
that didn't release the product
yet, that they're second product
market a MAC and hoodie walking
down university avenue in Palo
Alto.  The truth is product
challenge is a never ending
challenge.  You live it every
single day in this amazing
journey of building successful
products that drive successful
businesses.  It doesn't matter
if you have zero users, 10K
users or 10 million users, you
ask yourself: What should I
build now?  And I'd like to
start in sharing a story with
you.  It is a story
of a good friend of mine.  She
wanted to be here, but couldn't
make it. is Rony.  She writes
Android code and iOS code and
has this lovely dog named Nala.
And Nala loves Android.
likes to go outside, go on long
walks, hang out in the park.
Nala is a playful dog and
super-friendly, and likes to
play with other dogs as well.
One day, Rony thought, hey, why
don't I build a hyperhyperlocal
network for dogs and owners.
Being this super awesome girl,
that's what she did.  She sat
down over the weekend and came
up with the app and let you see
other dog owners walking their
dogs around you.  You can know
when to walk the dog and
potentially make new friends for
you and your pets.  And she
released this, what you might
call MPP.  Boom.  She tweets
about it.  Blogger picks it
up.  20,000 installs, 5,000
daily active user, users that
use have MVP$200,000 in seed
money and focus on adding
feature, in other words,
building our product.  Rony is
smart.  I can't say that too
many times.  She knows
everything about a startup, and
she knows she needs to validate
thing, and do user research.
That's exactly the very first
thing she's doing.  builds this
amazing landing page, again,
featuring Nala, telling people
about the product that she's
about to release and allowing
them to leave their e-mail
address if they're interested to
hear more about it or join a
private beta.  And of course,
she checks conversion
rates.  sends out notifications
to the loyal users and ask hey,
would you like user ratings or
that or that in the app.  Users
can say yes or no, and of
course, she checks conversion
rates.  Lastly
, just to be extra sure, she
went out and spoke to her users,
like the real world, speaking
with them.  She buys them
coffee, shows them her mockups
and asks them three questions.
Would you use it?  you pay for
it?  And how much will you pay
for it?   her user research, she
builds what she thinks is a
great
product.  She publishing it on
app store and Google Play, ready
to takeoff, but unfortunately
she crashes. didn't get the
traction she wants.  Let's see,
let's look at what went wrong
here.  very first thing Rony did
was using a landing page.  She
used it in order to figure out
if people
want such an app, if people
need it.  In fact, landing page
can answer only one single
question: Are people interested
enough to give me their e-mail a
doesn't say anything about do
people need it and will people
use it.  The second thing that
Rony did is listening to her
users, either in person or via
push notifications.  But the
very first rule in user research
is ... never listen to users!
know it sounds funny, but bear
with me for a moment.  listen to
your users, instead ... watch
and observe their behavior.  The
reason is that we, human being,
we're very bad at predicting
our own behavior.  There is
almost zero correlation between
what we say we will do and what
we actually do.  Psychologists
know that, researchers know
that, developers
don't.  So I'm here to help.
Let's see what Rony could have
done differently.  I will
introduce you to a methodology
proved to be working.  Build,
experiment, optimize.  Now,
being an engineer, I feel very
comfortable with the build s
tuff.  To
me, writing code is not a job,
it is a hobby.   I like to do.
That's my sweet spot.   I'm not
the only one in the room.  Let's
move to experiment.  What is a
good experiment?  What do I w am
I looking for in my
experiments?  A good
experiment is fast.  I want to
get results quickly.  I don't
want to wait forever to figure
out what my next move is.  A
good experiment is
efficient I like to run
experiment without investing a
lot of manpower.  like to run
experiment -- it doesn't matter
if we are talking about a small
team or big team, ideally, one
person will be able to run --
and manage multiple experiments
simultaneously.  And last but
not least, good experiments
provide me with real data.  your
users, remember, observe their
behavior.  We act upon real
data, not gut feeling.  I need a
system that will allow me to
track data, analyze it, act upon
it all in one place.  Make
data-driven decisions.  Now,
unfortunately, if you wanted to
run experiments, you would have
to use multiple products from
analytics to AB systems to push
analytics and what not.  You
need to integrate Android and
iOS and write code on the
service side.  You need to face
some data integration issue and
deal with data discrepancy
between system.  means you don't
have one single place with all
the data.  Well, that was the
situation until we
announced Firebase today.  If
you have been to the keynote
today, I probably heard about
haven't heard the keynote, then
I suggest you get up, find a
way to travel back in time and
watch the keynote.  Because the
keynote was awesome.  And for
the keynote, there's a T-shirt h
ere.  All right.   know, can I
get a "hell yeah" for the
keynote.  Let's do AP testing.
This side, can I get a hell
yeah!  What about that side?
T-shirt goes that way.
[Laughter]
right, Firebase, Firebase is a
suit of integrated products to
help you build your app, grow
your app and earn money.  It
helps you build your app and
make money. know and understand
there is more than one platform
out there.  Firebase has all the
great features you can see
here.  I will obviously not go
over all of them.  I will focus
on what makes Firebase a great
experiment
al analytics.  the heart of the
Firebase platform.  It is free
and unlimited.  Now you can
learn and understand everything
your users are doing without c
ompromising.  100% free.   no
hits limits, no quota, no
sampling, 100% for free.  And
automatic event reporting.  When
you integrate Firebase
Analytics into your product
without adding any lines of
code, we track key events, like
apple pays
-- app updates, and out of the
box key metrics, like monthly
active user, average revenue per
user, average revenue per
paying user, and more.  is so
powerful because
it is tightly integrated with
Firebase and with Google.  Now,
you can take the data, make some
insights and immediately turn
the insights into action item.
we'll see how you do that later.
And last, it's your data.  All
the data that we track and
collect in Firebase Analytics is
your data, with very few single
clicks, very few clicks, you
can export all your data to
BigQuery, connect it to whatever
tables you have and run
anything from queries to machine
learning to prediction API.  It
is your data.  Now, let's take
a look at what it takes to add
Firebase Analytics into your
product.  You start at the
Firebase console.  And you get
this lovely screen where you can
add Android app, iOS app or web
app, you go small configuration
phase, get a config file to
download to your product.  Then
a single line of code in iOS
grabbing from graddella  --
Gradle file, and you have that
done and you get it right out of
the Box 1, seven, 30-day, to
retention cohorts, and
demographics and so much more.
time to go through all of it, I
will focus on the things that m
atter to us.  Remember our goal?
We want to watch and observe
our users behavior.  see how
Firebase Analytics helps us do
that.  many other analytics
systems, Firebase Analytics is
an event-centric system.  That
means it tracks and collects
event.  Logging event is super,
super easy.  50, grab a
reference to Firebase Analytics
object and initialize it.  And
then use the API.  This is how I
would use it when a user clicks
an item in my app to view more
details about it.  As you can
see, the API is straightforward.
You build a bundle and call
log event with that bundle.
Now, deciding what to log and
when can sometimes
be tricky.  That's why we came
up with some suggested schemas,
like you see here.  Item I.D.,
item name, content type.  Of c
ourse, you can use whatever
schemas you want, in case you
don't like
ours.  Once you go back to the
console, you can see the events
and drill down an event to see
more information about it.  Now
thing is we want to track user's
flow, we don't want to track
single interaction.  We want to
track the whole interaction,
what the user is doing.  That is
where funnels come to help.
Funnels come to help.  Great.
So finally the series of events
that are important to us, that
we're interested in.  As soon as
you define a funnel, let's see
user browse through items, add
an item to a cart and purchase
it, that is a series of events
we're interested in, when we
define the funnel, Firebase
Analytics will track and go
through the journey and tell us
what is the conversion rate?
How many users went from one
state to another?   added an
item to the cart?  How many
actually made a purchase?  It is
great to check where you are
losing users and where you need
to improve.  I said Firebase
Analytics is an event-centric
system, but it is also
That makes it unique.  We know
that users are not the same.
Different users behave
differently.  In order to really
understand our users and what
they're doing, we need to be
able to define different groups
of users.  We call those groups
audiences.  we need to breakdown
every single report based on
those groups or audiences,
everything from funnels to
events, to
ARPs and everything, when you
think of an audience, you think
of males, versus females,
different age groups, maybe some
location, language or some
other common attributes like
device, OS version, app version,
et cetera.  Firebase Analytics
has all that, but it also lets
you define your own user
property, like, I don't know,
users that shared an item at
least once.  Or users that
reached level 5 in my
game.  Remember what we need
from our experiment framework.
takes care of providing us with
real data and data we can act u
pon, but we still need to be
able to make quick and fast
changes in our app and the way
our app behaves.  This is
exactly why we built remote
config.  As a matter of fact,
remote config started as an
internal system we used at
Google.  First, we used it in
the framework, GMS and opened it
to internal apps like Gmail,
Play.  It saved us so many times
and proved to be so valuable to
us, we said all right.  Maybe
other developers can benefit
from it.  We open it up today on
Android and iOS.  Remote config
lets you store key value pairs
and lets you store them.  You
can save language, device, app
version, OS version, et cetera.
And do stage rollouts to change
values to 10% of the users in
North America.  And since
everything is so integrated with
analytics, you can target
different audiences with remote
config.  For example, let's say
I'm building this great game and
I'm not sure how hard I need to
make this game.  So I set up
with remote config, the game
difficulty level.  I can change
it remotely.  But I can do even
more.  Let's say I can make the
game harder for people who reach
level 5 in less than two days
and I can make the game easier
for people who are struggling
with level 1 for more than two
hours, so they won't get
frustrated.  You know what,
let's see how I would do that.
First, I initialize remote
config and set some different
values to it.  Just in case I
don't have a network or
something, I do have the
different values.   call fetch
and activate fetch to grab the
new values from the
server.  Anywhere in my app, I
can use the values in my get by
calling get in, get string, as
simple as that. Don't worry
about calling multiple fetches
and stuff.  We have caching
mechanism and we know how to
turn the caches valid to may
fetch a no-op.  There is a good
remote config talk, I think,
tomorrow.  All right. k to
our game plan.  So with
Firebase Analytics and remote
config, I can run experiments
and change my game difficulty
level pretty easily.  But I
still don't know what is the
right difficulty level that I
should stick with.  In other
words, what am I trying to
optimize here?  Now, everything
that you optimize, everything
that you change every feature
that you add, every little thing
in your app needs to show
significant improvement in one
of the three.  Conversion from
free to paid.  Actual users that
are paying for your app, paying
for your service.  Time spent
in app, increase the time that
users are using your product.
And retention.  Make your users
use your product or app more
often.  So I'd like to show you
how App in the Air used this
framework -- a very similar
framework and Firebase to learn
the experiments, learn and
optimize the product and their
business.  So up in the air is
basically a personal travel
assistant.  It gives you
consistency and all the
resources and information that
you need about your flight and
travel regardless of the airline
and all the flight.  They
released an SDK so other
developers can plug into it.
What I like about up in the air,
it has additional features that
save you time and money and
airport trips and queue for
security in the airport.  I like
that.  Let's see how App in the
Air used Firebase to validate
what they are doing.  First
thing they did is define funnel
that represents the main goal of
the app, or their main KPI, if
you wish, which is user openers
the app adds a flight and makes
a purchase.  That's the core
metric of the business.  Define
the funnel and this is what they
got.   see 29% of the users
added a flight and 7.2% of those
users actually made a purchase.
That is across all users.  So
they started filtering this
funnel based on different
demographics and other
parameters, actually, they used
about 18 different properties
and attributes to filter and
take a look -- take a deeper
look at what their users are
doing.  And here are some
interesting things that they've
learned.  Users between age 18
and 24 have
two times --
yeah.  They have two time add
flight conversion.   more
flights.  And they have
1.5 times purchase flight
conversion.  Purchase
conversion.  They looked at
other properties and found that
users running Marshmallow also
convert better.  Almost two
times add flight and
1.4 times make a purchase.
Just by looking at Firebase
Analytics with audiences,
breaking out what users are
doing, they immediately got some
very interesting and crucial
action items.  First, we need to
investigate why we have this
difference in performance.
Second, let's check issues on
bad OS versions.  Maybe users
with Kit Kat, the app doesn't
crash in Kit Kat, but maybe
there is a problem there.  Maybe
we're slow, maybe we're
lagging, maybe there is a glitch
in the UI.  I don't know.  But
it is worse --
it makes sense to experiment
that.  And it allows them to
know which users to engage, that
are more likely to make a p
urchase.  So one of the things
that they decided to check was
the onboarding process of the
app. used remote config, as you
can see to define a quick
experiment.  50% of users will
get a welcome screen explaining
what the app is doing.  And they
will get one free credit to get
flight --  the service before
they buy.  And the other 50% of
the users will not get the
welcome screen, will not get the
free credit for flight alerts.
And they compared the
conversion rate, based on those
groups.  When they compared,
this is what they saw.
At-flight conversion is pretty
similar.  The welcome screen,
not having a welcome screen
configurated didn't change the
add flights.  But one group
actually purchased two times
more than the other group.
Here's the question for you guys
and girls.  Which group
purchased more?  The group that
got a nice welcome screen,
hello, welcome to App in the
Air, here's a free credit, try
before you buy. The group that
installed the app, opened it and
immediately in the screen they
needed to figure out what to do?
Who thinks it is the group
with the welcome screen?  Who
thinks it is the group with the
no welcome
screen?  Who doesn't think?
[Laughter] All right.  That's
exactly why you need to make
data-driven decision and not gut
feeling.  having a welcome
screen and offering a free
credit made people buy less.
the very first call to action
that App in the Air did was
going back to remote config and
change that group that doesn't
get a welcome screen from 50% to
100%, and the
result?   Two times purchase
across both iOS and Android.
Actually, the team that
implemented all of that is
sitting
here.  Another thing that they
did, which is very interesting,
App in the Air, they render an
application service -- server,
sorry, on app engine.   the
server, in the backend, they
have lots of data about users,
preferences, history of
purchases, and tons and tons of
stuff.  But now with Firebase
Analytics -- now with Firebase
Analytics, Firebase Analytics
also stores data about users'
behavior.   linked the two.
They started running some secret
sauce of prediction amp -- APIs
and crazy queries and found
something interesting.  They
found out there is a group of
users you can define based on
parameters, which is three times
more likely to fly business.
Okay?  Immediately as the user
opens the app, you can predict
that this user may fly business.
That means that those users,
they value convenience over
price.  So immediately, as soon
as a user in that group opens
the app the first time before
they do anything.  App in the
Air can customize the
suggestions, and the ads that
those users see, because they
know that maybe they like luxury
hotels or better cars or better
flights. this is what I call a
win-win-win.  the results from
this thing was a significant
increase, not only in the
conversion rate of how many
people actually purchased, but
also
in the average revenue per
paying user.  Again, win-win-win
just by looking at data and
data decisions.  So, back to
Rony.  She starts using Firebase
to validate her ideas and now
super happy.   a picture from t
oday, actually, that she sent
me.  super happy with new
friends for her and her dog,
Nala.  So for more information
about Firebase Analytics and
remote config and how you can
start using it today to validate
your ideas, run experiments and
optimize everything in your
app, go to our docs, our
support, and office hours today,
we just ran out of them.  There
are office hours tomorrow and
Friday, look for the people with
the yellow shirts that are
hanging around here.  They will
be more than happy to help you
integrate Firebase today.  Thank
you, everybody. Now, if you
have questions, I have some
time.  We have some time.
For this side.
Either nobody listened or
everybody understood everything.